[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans les matins du
sénat qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
dans la gestion de la crise sanitaire
qu'est ce qui peut être doit être
améliorée au niveau administratif
c'est tout l'objet de la commission
d'enquêté mise en place par le sénat
aujourd'hui la commission s'intéresse à
la gestion de la crise dans le
département de l'oise
on regarde d'audition n'en reparle juste
après à la nuit du 26 au 27 février
dernier ouais ça a été traité comme le
serait un foyer épidémique d'aujourd'hui
avant que le passage en phase iii ne
conduise à renoncer à des modes
opératoires qui nous ont été
réintroduits qu'au moment du des
confirmands notamment en terme de
contacts racing ce foyer épidémique a
fait l'objet d'une étude d'une équipe de
l'institut pasteur sous la direction du
professeur fontanes et qui pourra nous
apporter un éclairage intéressant aux
côtés des différents acteurs de la crise
comment la gestion de la crise est-elle
organisée dans le département quels en
sont les retours d'expériences quels
enseignements avez-vous tiré les uns et
les autres de cet épisode
si une autre crise devait survenir ce
sont notamment ces questions que nous en
rapporte heures nos collègues vous
poseront donc je vais vous demander à
chacun de vous présenter brièvement de
faire quelques propos introductif mais
compte tenu du nombre d'intervenants
d'essayer d'être très synthétique j'en
suis désolé puisque nous rentrerons dans
les détails à travers les questions qui
vous seront posées
merci et puis ensuite je mangerais bien
sûr à nos commissaires à nora porter en
priorité d'être aussi concis précis dans
les questions comme ils l'ont été tous
ces jours ci de façon à ce que chacun
puisse largement s'exprimer alors
auparavant et conformément à la
procédure applicable aux commission
denquête je vais vous demander bien sûr
de prêter serment
je rappelle que tout témoignage
mensonger devant une commission d
enquête parlementaire et punis puni de
cinq ans d'emprisonnement et 75 mille
euros damende monsieur etienne champions
prêtez-vous serment de 10
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je le jure je le
jure même cécile marie cécile d'armoy
prêté serment dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité levé la main droite et
dire edit je le jure monsieur louis
lefranc prêté serment également de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je te jure je le
jure madame nadège lefebvre prêté
serment de dire la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je
jure et arnaud fontanet prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
ait levé la main droite et dit je le
jure le jure merci alors nous commençons
notre tour de table dans l'ordre que
vous souhaitez mais je pense que le
faire alors de dans lequel vous vous
trouvez
monsieur le préfet c'est bien monsieur
le président que je vais commencer j'ai
essayé d'être aussi concis et précis
donc il m'a été imparti lire quelques
minutes simplement vous dire que ma
première pensée va vers toutes les
personnes qui malheureusement ont perdu
la vie dans ce département le canton de
l'oise en est à 1 591 personnes décédées
et remercier toutes celles et ceux ici
présents et aussi dans le département de
l'oise avec directeur général de la rs
et et les élus qui ont contribué pour
faire en sorte que cette pandémie ne
soit pas encore plus graves que ce qu
elle a pu être pour moi il ya quatre
maîtres mots qui sous tendent l'action
publique
quand j'ai l'action publique c'est aussi
bien celles de l'état que des
collectivités territoriales dans le
département de l'oise
tout d'abord une cohérence une
anticipation de postures anticipation
une transparence et la réactivité alors
la cohérence tout d'abord la stratégie
pour nous l'intention a été dès
l'apparition des premières des premiers
symptômes des personnes contaminées dont
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure et pour
l'une pour lesquelles ça s'est mal
terminée très mal terminé d'ailleurs
puisque ça a entraîné son décès la
tension était de ralentir la propagation
du virus qui étaient concentrées dans le
quart sud-est de l'oise afin de disposer
des délais nécessaires à la mise en
oeuvre des mesures de protection de
l'ensemble de la population de l'oise
donc c'est vraiment cette stratégie qui
a sous-tendu notre action et puis dire
que naturellement et par cohérence
l'état local en gildas locales ces
régionales avec le directeur général de
la rs mais aussi la rectrice de
l'académie d'amiens et le préfet de
l'oise on a fait bloc pour définir les
orientations nous permettant de mettre
en oeuvre cette stratégie
ensuite on l'a partagée avec les élus
premier rang desquels la présidente du
conseil départemental puisque sur un
savon d'établissement je pense aux ehpad
où elle est en coresponsabilité l agence
régionale de la santé
il a fallu définir toute une série de
mesures et le faire en toute
transparence le faire aussi avec les
maires et le salue monsieur bruno
fortier et maire de crépy en valois ici
présents inquiéter l'épicentre de cette
crise pas uniquement pandémique mais
aussi médiatique avec lequel il a fallu
se concerter tous les jours pour adapter
les mesures nécessaires à la gestion de
cette pandémie d'une polémique avec et d
extraordinairement longs dans le
département on a démarré les purs 1er
mai on a fini aussi les derniers donc le
choc pas seulement sanitaire mais
économique est bien plus fort dans
l'oise que dans tous les départements de
france et de navarre ensuite
l'anticipation d'anticipation et de
réactivité d'anticipation je vous donner
quelques exemples
j'étais confronté à un problème de
gestion des personnes décédées il a
fallu augmenter faire passer de six à
dix jours par exemple les délais
d'inhumation augmenté
la capacité de crémation des corps donc
ça a été un problème important parce
qu'il s'est avéré au mois de mars en
particulier quand on a eu on a eu des we
can où on a eu jusqu'à 20 25 voire 30
morts à gérer donc on a été confrontée à
ces difficultés et il a fallu mettre en
adéquation notre propre dispositif de
gestion des personnes décédées avec les
capacités locales le fait de les
réajuster avec des mesures
réglementaires d'expliquer aux élus
parce que je dois vous dire que
traverser au mois de mars
quelques frayeurs des opérateurs
funéraires avait menacé de laisser les
cercueils sur les routes
certains d'entre eux en particulier dans
le quart sud est du département
autre exemple aussi en matière
d'anticipation la gestion du ramadhan
notamment de la rupture du jeûne sur le
plateau de creil de tradition tous les
ans il ya des milliers de gens qui se
rassemblent et donc pour l'avoir vécu
dans ton qu'observateur an dernier avec
les équipes peuvent équipage de police
des brigades anti criminalité
je voyais déjà se profiler directeur
général et resterai pas m'écouter
également la deuxième vague de pandémie
dans l'oise donc il a fallu là aussi en
liaison étroite avec les maires de la
petite agglomération de creil comme cent
mille habitants et les responsables
cultuel musulman ainsi que les imams les
réunira plusieurs reprises à la
préfecture et chez eux pour leur faire
comprendre qu'il n'y avait pas lieu de
pratiquer la rupture du jeûne qui se
serait traduite par plusieurs milliers
de personnes rassemblées sur un plateau
dans l'espace un certain ouvert mais où
le cluster de creil était toujours bien
des esprits voilà donc voilà en matière
de d'anticipation ce que j'étais amené à
faire réactivité alors la réactivité et
s'est traduite par un dispositif un peu
innovant qui consistait à prendre un
arrêté préfectoral à plusieurs arrêtés
préfectoraux successifs de portée
générale d'hier droit dur et droit soupe
foire aux questions pour éviter de
prendre des arrêtés préfectoraux tous
les jours donc droit soupe foire aux
questions s'étaient mis en ligne sur les
réseaux et les élus mais aussi la
population de l'oise pouvez consulter
très facilement tous des adaptations qui
était faite au quotidien vraiment pour
coller au terrain
donc c'est comme ça qu'on a procédé
cette foire aux questions étaient
dire aussi lu que les meilleures bandes
illustré qui peuvent intéresser une
catégorie de nos jeunes mais je dois
vous dire cette fois en question ça a
été vraiment pour moi pour mes équipes
le meilleur moyen de diffuser une
information aussi précise que possible
vers les chefs d'entreprises vers les
responsables associatifs et vers les
élus alors tout ce travail là on l'a
fait évidemment en toute transparence un
bulletin quotidien ferait par conjoint
devant le directeur général de la rs et
moi-même en direction donc du grand
public d'abord des mères non un partage
constant avec la président du conseil
départemental
je ne saurais vous dire combien de fois
nous sommes vus à la préfecture au
conseil départemental pour ajuster le
dispositif de gestion de ce que je
qualifierais de la petite enfance
ça a été un travail vraiment quotidien
travaille de concert qu'il fallait mener
et et ce travail s'est traduit donc par
cette information sur les réseaux
sociaux sur des publications
d'information quotidienne réactualisé au
quotidien et puis concernant les
parlementaires comme n'est plus sous
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
la possibilité de cumuler les mandats il
fallait bien que je tienne comme
informés de ce qui se passe dans le
département donc à la fin de chaque
semaine un point global de 2 à 3 heures
sur tous les aspects de la gestion de la
pandémie sur les aspects sanitaires sur
les aspects économiques sur les aspects
sécurité et ce qui leur permettait
d'ailleurs de pouvoir répondre aux
nombreuses sollicitations de la presse
alors en matière de transparence pour la
presse un tout petit mot là aussi
monsieur le président le département de
l'oise pendant un mois a fait l'objet
d'une pression médiatique mais inouïe il
ya eu 300 journalistes de la presse
nationale internationale locale qui
étaient là en permanence qui
le maire de crépy en valois le sait
puisqu'il a eu malheureusement à y être
confronté bien que confiné lui même est
atteint par la crise à une partie de ses
collaborateurs ça a été une pression
médiatique extrêmement forte
alors quand vous parliez tout à l'heure
dans votre propos liminaire de ce qu'il
vous pourrez peut-être ce qui a été bien
vécue au mal vécu je vais pas vous dire
cd mal vécu ça fait partie du jeu certes
gestion d'une pandémie on sait très bien
de la presse va s'y intéresser mais
c'est quand même un élément plus
compliqué pour nous en tant que
gestionnaire de la crise parce qu'il
faut qu'on fasse évidemment attention ce
que l'on dit à ce que l'on fait à ce que
l'on dit par et et ça peut être de
nature aussi à provoquer d'autres effets
qui pourraient nous dépasser dans la
gestion de la pandémie voix très
rapidement le président ce que je
voulais me dire monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
moi aussi je voudrais commencer
évidemment par un hommage aux victimes
du coc vide
j'en citerai notamment deux monsieur
dominique varotto enseignants qui a été
le premier français décédés je me
souviendrai longtemps avec le monsieur
le préfet de notre arrivée à vaumoise le
jour même à la rencontre de le grand
nombre de citoyens qui étaient des amis
de monsieur var autour et ça a été une
entrée en matière extrêmement difficile
je pense aussi à au doctorat raffinera
nazis qui est le lui aussi le premier
médecin français et on voit si je vous
dis ça c'est parce qu'on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de premiers dans l'oise et
beaucoup des choses qui ont été dans
l'oise sont liées aussi à cette vague
qui est arrivé et qui était la première
au plus fort de la crise c'est
évidemment dans les hôpitaux dans les
dans les cabinets de ville dans les
ehpad que c'est trouver la réponse à
cette situation qui était inédite
ce sont les équipes soignantes et plus
largement les professionnels qui par
leur mobilisation extraordinaire ont
permis de faire front et c'est
l'occasion aussi aujourd'hui de saluer
leur professionnalisme notamment celui
de madame d'armoy qui a été certainement
elle aussi une des toutes premières
françaises confrontées en tant que
directrice d'établissement à ce qui
était totalement
inattendue cette crise a là aussi été
gérée organisée par l' agence régionale
de santé
moi je conçois lagence avant tout comme
une facilitatrice comme une instance qui
doit être dans la souplesse dans le
rapport entre le national et le local
pour permettre ce fonctionnement qui
doit avoir une certaine autonomie dans
le respect évidemment des règles
nationales mais surtout qui doit se
nourrir du terrain je me permets
aujourd'hui aussi de rendre hommage aux
équipes de la rs qui sont mobilisés dans
les coulisses depuis les premières
heures mais au sein des pouvoirs publics
monsieur le préfet l'a dit la rs n'est
évidemment pas seul elle n'a pas être
seul et je crois pas qu'elle c'est avant
tout un travail de coordination il a
parlé de ce trio avec aussi la rectrice
car les aspects scolaires ont été
importants et plus globalement un pack
impact que je crois nous avons pu
constituer avec l'ensemble des pouvoirs
publics qu'ils soient d'état ou
décentralisées les collectivités
territoriales évidemment l'articulation
avec les collectivités est extrêmement
importante
elle est passée évidemment par le préfet
mais au niveau de la rs aussi avec ma
directrice départementale nous avons
aussi essayé d'être le plus en relation
possible
vous avez invité à cette table ronde sur
crépy et sur l'oise parce qu'évidemment
les premiers éléments ont été ici je
voudrais dire que la crise n'a pas
commencé le 26 février dans la nuit du
25 au 26 février quand nous n'avons
appris ce premier décès ce premier cas
autochtone comme on dit en france dès le
23 janvier
nous avons commencé à préparer la crise
nous l'avons préparé avec les préfets
avec les établissements
nous avons commencé à organiser
régulièrement des conférences qui nous
ont permis de nous préparer
avec aussi les professionnels de santé
de ville
les fédérations médication médico
sociaux parce qu'il nous fallait nous
préparer pour moi l'ensemble des
scientifiques je pense notamment aux
grands spécialistes des hôpitaux c'était
une forme de conseil scientifique de
l'agencé régionale de santé
je ne vais pas revenir puisque le propos
est court sur sur les détails
comme l'a dit monsieur le préfet nous
étions à ce moment dans une cape
totalement nouveau il y avait eu un
cluster notamment en rhône alpes mais
c'était un cluster liée à une
importation de cas ce que nous
découvrons dans l'oise c'est quelque
chose de totalement différent
c'est à dire un virus qui circulent déjà
peut-être que le professeur fontanet
pourra il y faire plus détails
nous avions donc finalement une
confrontation avec une situation qui
n'était pas celle de quelqu'un qui
arrivait avec les caractéristiques un
jeu revient de chine jacent nous avions
des gens qui avaient eu le virus parce
que le virus circule est et ce qui a
posé évidemment un certain nombre de
sujets et notamment par le fait que
parce qu' aucune des caractéristiques de
ces patients ne correspondait à ce qu'on
appelle la définition de cas ils avaient
évidemment circuler dans les hôpitaux
sans que des précautions soient prises
non pas parce que il y aurait eu des
manquements mais tout simplement parce
qu' il ne pouvait pas à la a priori être
identifié c'est pourquoi un des enjeux
très importants
ça a été évidemment de pouvoir faire
donc ce qu'on appelle le contact racing
à la fois en ville mais aussi dans les
hôpitaux ce qui a posé évidemment un
sujet avec notamment à creil 1 la
nécessité de fermer provisoirement la
réanimation pour transférer les patients
et pour permettre la continuité
évidemment de leur prise en charge dès
le 27 février
j'ai sollicité l'appui de la réserve
sanitaire 1 avec un nombre très
important une réaction vraiment
immédiate du national cent dix
réservistes qui sont intervenus sur
cette cette zone
il ya eu ensuite parce qu'il y avait le
décès de cet enseignant de crépy en
valois mais aussi tout un travail de
dépistage qui s'est fait en deux temps à
la fois sur le coeur des personnes
susceptibles d'être contaminés et plus
largement avec le soutien de madame la
présidente du procès départementale plus
largement sur les établissements
scolaires
de kribi juste très rapidement dire que
cette première expérience pour moi m'a
permis de dégager je crois quatre
principes que nous avons ensuite essayé
d'appliquer à l'ensemble de la gestion
de crise dans l'oise et dans la région
penser et agir à 360° sur le champ de la
santé mais aussi du médico-social du
régional au local en lien évidemment
toujours avec le national la
mobilisation des hôpitaux publics mais
aussi privés les acteurs de la chaîne de
prise en charge notamment des samu mais
aussi en lien avec l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'urgence et du secours
la consolidation des passerelles entre
la ville et l'hôpital
et puis bien sûr l'accompagnement des
professionnels de tous les secteurs et
notamment des professionnels de ville
avec un travail très approfondi que nous
avons menées et notamment la mise en
place de la télémédecine j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir plus en détail
protéger les plus fragiles avec tout un
travail des mesures que nous avons
prises avant même les mesures nationales
sur les ehpad
je ne développe pas puisque mon temps et
est avancé être connecté en permanence
avec les territoires tout en assurant le
lien avec le national monsieur le préfet
a cité un goût certain nombre d'exemples
je préciserai aussi que à l'initiative
du préfet de région tous les lundis à
compter du 2 mars s'est tenue ce que
nous avons appelé ce qu'il a appelé la
conférence stratégique dans lequel il y
avait l'ensemble des préfets l'ensemble
des présidents de conseils
départementaux l'ensemble des président
était président de l'association des
maires et moi même bien sûr qui a permis
aussi des tags à des bulletins ono moi
même un j'adresse au delà des bulletins
que nous avons fait aujourd'hui encore à
l'ensemble des élus et notamment aux
sénateurs à l'ensemble des partenaires
des parlementaires pardon un bulletin
qui est aujourd'hui hebdomadaire qui a
été un peu plus fréquents présent il ya
un point à la fois départemental et
national
enfin dernier point s'adapter en temps
réel faire collectivement face à
l'imprévu je crois que monsieur le
préfet l'a dit nous avons été dans une
situation totalement nouvelle que
personne
est connue et je crois que c'était cette
capacité effectivement à la fois à
mettre en oeuvre un certain nombre
d'instructions qui nous venaient du
national mais aussi d'être créatif
collectivement avec les professionnels
en premier lieu avec les élus qui nous a
permis j'espère de répondre au mieux aux
défis qui nous était donnée vision la
parole à madame la présidente monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
vice président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
tout d'abord je vous remercie de m'avoir
invité à témoigner devant votre
commission denquête en effet le
département de l'oise comme il a été
rappelé tout à l'heure a été au tout
début du mois de mars le premier
territoire métropolitain véritablement
touché par l'épidémie
c'est dans l'oise que les premiers
regroupements de personnes contaminées
les fameux cluster ont été identifiés
ainsi des mesures de confinement
touchant en particulier des
établissements scolaires ont visé des
zones cluster de l'oise dès le 2 mars la
semaine
une semaine plus tard c'est à dire le 9
mars les écoles collèges écoles collèges
lycées et de l'ensemble du département
étaient fermées et une semaine qu'une
semaine d'avant ce bien sûr sur le reste
du territoire national
ainsi notre territoire a été pris très
tôt dans la tourmente de l'épidémie le
fait que loi soit le premier territoire
touché nous a placés comme disait
monsieur le préfet tout à leur sens que
nous n'y soyons vraiment préparé sous
les feux des projecteurs tous les
acteurs de l'oise qu'il s'agisse des
collectivités des entreprises pour
certaines mises à l'écart un forum aussi
le signaler par leur client au motif
qu'elle était de l'oise ou des services
de l'état ont été durement touchée
pendant les premières semaines de cette
crise alors que nous ne connaissons pas
nous ne connaissons pas à l'époque un
grand chose sur ce virus nous avons dû
faire face aux assauts médiatique qui
ont il faut bien le dire
mais notre département sous les feux des
projecteurs ce qui rendait pas les
choses faciles au quotidien nous avons
aussi affronté avec quelques jours ou
semaines d'avancé sur les autres
territoires des problématiques complexes
la pénurie de masques qui touchait bien
sûr les médecins généralistes mais aussi
d'autres services comme les services
d'aidé à domicile
ces derniers sont souvent repartis
bredouilles des pharmacies qui était
censé leur procurer les équipements de
protection indispensable pour l'exercice
de leur métier
le traitement de la situation
particulière des assistantes maternelles
d'abord confronté à des questions liées
à la prise en charge des enfants qui
leur étaient habituellement confiées
puis à celle de l'indemnisation des
journées non travaillées
j'ai été je crois la première à saisir
le gouvernement pour qu'elle puisse
comme les autres salariés bénéficier
d'une sorte de chômage partiel qui leur
étaient initialement refusé je tiens à
saluer aujourd'hui bien sûr l'action des
habitants de l'oise durant cette période
mais aussi pendant tout le confinement
qui a suivi je veux souligner en
particulier l'engagement de nombreux
élus locaux dont le maire de crépy en
valois à mes côtés comme une parmi les
plus durement touchées en france
ils ont été sur le pont pour aider leurs
administrés en particulier les plus
fragiles
je tiens aussi à saluer l'action du
préfet de l'oise qui a cherché à nos
côtés comme le disait comme il le disait
tout à l'heure
sans relâche à apporter les réponses les
plus adaptées à des besoins aussi urgent
que difficile à satisfaire
l'action du conseil départemental s'est
concentrée autour de cinq axes le
premier la prise en charge des personnes
âgées qu'elles soient en ehpad dans
d'autres établissements ou à domicile
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes
âgées à domicile l'aide aux autres
publics fragiles qu'il s'agisse des
personnes handicapées en difficulté
sociale ou des jeunes de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance n'oublions pas que durant
toute cette période
eh bien tous les enfants bien sûr les
enfants n'allaient pas à l'école ils
étaient dans les foyers et c'était quand
même très difficile à gérer l'accueil
des élèves aussi dans les collèges
savoir les enfants des personnels
prioritaires pendant le confinement puis
l'accompagnement des établissements pour
la mise en oeuvre
du protocole sanitaire pendant la phase
de déconfinement ces trois axes sont
évidemment au coeur des compétences de
la collectivité
pour autant nous avons dû plus d'une
fois aller au delà de nos stricte
compétence pour faire face à l'urgence à
ceux ci se sont ajoutés une aide
d'urgence nous avons décidé pour les
travailleurs non salariés qui ne
pouvaient pas bénéficier de mesures de
chômage partiel
il y en avait énormément dans le
département l'aide de 1500 euros mise en
place par l'état servait pour nombre
d'entre eux à payer les charges de
l'entreprise de telle sorte qu'ils ne
retrouvaient pas il n'avait pas de
possibilité quelquefois pour nourrir
leur famille ou payer leur loyer entre
parenthèses ses 3500 oz de cette nature
qui ont été données à des chefs
d'entreprise le soutien aux personnes en
première ligne à savoir les personnels
des ehpad des services dead et
d'accompagnement à domicile mais aussi
les ambulanciers les pompes funèbres ou
encore les chauffeurs de taxi notre
action dans ce domaine a permis à une
époque où les masques manqué partout que
ce soit au niveau des cabinets médicaux
ou des établissements sociaux de
collecter des milliers de masques
conserver notamment dans des mairies
quelquefois dans des entreprises
depuis des années ces deux axes ne sont
pas spécifiquement du ressort du conseil
départemental particulièrement le
soutien aux personnes en première ligne
qui a le plus souvent consisté à fournir
des masques ou du matériel de protection
en attendant les livraisons de la rs ou
en complément de dotation qui était
parfois un peu juste bien sûr je parle
de la première période
sachant qu'après bien sûr ça s'est
sérieusement améliorée pendant toute
cette période cette longue période
j'ai souhaité que le conseil
départemental mène de front de bataille
la première qui consistait à faire face
à une situation d'urgence
particulièrement critique dans les ehpad
et plus largement pour les personnes
âgées
tout ou presque isolée par les mesures
de confinement
je pense aussi à la situation des
enfants qui n'était plus scolarisée et
qui pour certains ont perdu tout contact
avec le système éducatif
deux mille huit cents enfants de l'oise
ont été dans ce cas devant la gravité de
cette situation j'avais interpellé le
secrétaire d'état chargé de la
protection de l'enfance à ce sujet mais
je les attends encore la réponse la
seconde pour préparer l'après crise et
qui s'est traduit par le maintien de
notre calendrier de réunions notamment
nos commissions de façon à a toujours
accordé les marchés etc de façon à ce
que les entreprises est un signe fort
que la reprise pouvait s'opérer
rapidement dès le consulter le
déconfinement vous en doutez
certainement la gestion de cette crise
n'a pas été sans difficulté devant votre
commission il est évident évidemment
essentiel de mettre le doigt sur les
difficultés que nous avons rencontrées
de les analyser pour tirer les leçons de
cette expérience que nous ne souhaitons
pas bien évidemment revivre cette crise
a pourtant mis en lumière quelques
faiblesses dans l'organisation d'une
part l'organisation régionaliser de
certains services de l'état a montré ses
limites
en effet alors que loi c'était bien plus
touchés que les autres départements des
hauts de france de très loin du moins
bien sûr au mois de mars
beaucoup de temps a été perdu en
échanges régionaux avec des préfets ou
des présidents de conseils
départementaux confrontés à des
situations très différentes de la nôtre
je pense qu'il fallait qu'il y ait
surtout des points précis département
par département et qu'on s'éparpille pas
comme ça sur l'ensemble de la région
surtout je vous dis toujours dans la
première partie de cette de cette crise
au niveau du département de l'oise donc
malgré la force de frappe de la rs nous
avons eu quelques difficultés pour
l'approvisionnement en masques des ehpad
et des établissements sociaux et médico
sociaux en général je pense aussi aux
ambulanciers aux taxis conventionnés par
l'assurance maladie et surtout aux
pompes funèbres jeu je ne vais pas
développer monsieur le préfet l'a fait
tout à l'heure qui sont venues frapper
aussi à la porte du département pour
obtenir quelques milliers de masques
et protéger ainsi des centaines de
personnes particulièrement exposées au
virus
et pourtant oublié au contraire la
proximité du département notre
connaissance un bien sûr des acteurs
locaux a permis de collecter de
distribuer des milliers de masques
éparpillés sur tout le territoire
d'autre part la double tutelle exercée
par le département et la rs sur les
ehpad et quand même complexe mais c'est
quelque chose qu'on avait déjà identifié
avant les directeurs d'ehpad devait en
permanence jongler avec les
interlocuteurs selon la nature de leurs
besoins mais parfois aussi pour obtenir
des masques
j'ai noté que cet éloignement n'avait
pas été perçue de la même manière par
les élus d'alsace c'est un point que je
tiens j'y assiste sur ce point autres
territoires aussi lourdement touchée par
l'épidémie
cela tient peut-être de la proximité du
département et de la ville de strasbourg
où se trouve la région autrement dit la
régionalisation n'a sans doute pas les
mêmes conséquences pour les territoires
proches de la capitale régionale où les
acteurs travaillent de longues dates
ensemble que pour ceux comme l'oise dans
les hauts de france qui sont très
éloignées bien sûr de lille donc en
dépit de ces difficultés je mesure bien
sûr l'engagement de tous les acteurs
publics
que ce soit les services de l'état la rs
et tous les élus locaux et c'est une
crise sans précédent que nous souhaitons
bien sûr ne jamais revivre et on espère
on croise les doigts qui est pas de
deuxième vague
nous devons bien sûr tirer de cette
crise les leçons qui s'imposent et je
suis certaine que le travail de votre
commission pourra y remédier merci merci
madame la présidente je vais passer la
parole à monsieur le maire avant il
convient de vous rappeler monsieur le
maire que l'exercice consiste à
présenter en quelques minutes
effectivement les faits marquants nous
rentrerons dans le détail à travers les
questions de nos rapporteur est guy nos
commissaires mais avant il faut vous
rappeler que nous sommes une commission
sous serment
je vais vous demander de prêter serment
vous rappeler que tout témoignage
mensonger devant notre commission est
puni de cinq ans d'emprisonnement et 75
me
euros d'amande alors monsieur le maire
bruno fortier prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je le jure je le
jeu très bien monsieur le maire bien sûr
monde s'est prêté à cet exercice et je
vous laisse la parole pour un propos
liminaire
alors mon propos liminaire va
complètement changer à ce que ce qui
vient d'être dit je vais vous raconter
mon histoire
jeudi 13 février dernier conseil
communautaire à crépy-en-valois de notre
communauté de communes avec 91
conseillers communautaires
le mardi 25 février je dis à mon épouse
je ne sens pas du tout cette histoire de
coronavirus on parlait de la chine ont
parlé de l'italie ont commencé à parler
de la france et ce même jour je demande
à mon directeur de général des services
de faire le point sur le stock de
masques depuis l'épidémie de grippe h a
h1n1
résultat plus de masques en stock jeudi
27 février à 7h30 téléphone du directeur
général de la rs monsieur champions que
je ne connaissais pas et qui m'annonce
malheureusement le décès de monsieur
dominique va auto premier mort français
de cette cochonnerie comme je les
appelais et je continuerai de l'appeler
ils me demandent d'organiser une réunion
à 14 heures en mairie avec monsieur le
préfet monsieur le sous préfet monsieur
le député monsieur champions et puis
quelques autres personnes 8h30 je suis
en mairie pour réunir tout le personnel
d'accueil et prévenir qu' une influence
de jean la liste parce que je
connaissais bien allez certainement
arriver et bien sûr comme je connais
tout le monde à la mairie
je serre des mains je fais des bises et
et on continue réunion de la rs ce même
jour donc à 14 heures et puis le 28
février téléphone de la rs qui me
demande de faire une liste des membres
du conseil communautaire puisque une des
conseillères communautaire valérie mérou
conseillère communautaire d'une petite
commune de rouville
était malade et se trouvait à l'hôpital
de tourcoing
donc cette personne me dit voilà il faut
nous donner la liste des membres du
conseil communautaire pas de problème et
et puis et puis j'étais moi même malade
je toussais fortement et la personne de
lairesse me dit monsieur le maire faut
pas rester comme ça il faut aller faire
un test à l'hôpital d'amiens 29 février
le samedi premier test avec une de mes
concerts comme une conseillère
municipale très malade qui fait un
malaise dans la salle d'attentes et le
dimanche 1er mars
résultat du test vers 20h par de libos
je suis donc positif à cette cochonnerie
et la galère commence dans un engrenage
terrible qui se met en route
je vous donne maintenant le message que
j'ai fait passer sur les réseaux sociaux
bonsoir à tous après avoir subi un test
hier à l'hôpital d'amiens mon résultat
vient de tomber mon test est positif et
je suis porteur de cette cochonnerie
je suis donc en train d'établir une
liste des personnes que j'ai rencontrées
depuis les 14 derniers jours je pense
que beaucoup de cas voir apparaître dans
les jours qui viennent je ne suis pas
hospitalisés je ne me sentais pas malade
pas de fièvre mais je suis porteur de ce
satané virus cher crespinoise cher
crépynois nous entrons dans une période
difficile gardons notre calme
respectons les mesures imposées par la
préfecture et soyons solidaires merci
encore de votre soutien je vais vous
lire un dernier texte et puis je
m'arrêterai là et je répondrai à toutes
les questions
c'est un message de présentation de ma
commune aux professeurs à wayne
directeur de la recherche médicale de
l'institut pasteur et en copie
professeurs se vanner crépy en valois
est une ville charmante de 15 mille
trois cent cinquante sept habitants qui
a vécu depuis 182 un drame national
c'est la ville de l'accident de beaune
le 31 juillet 1982 quarante-quatre
enfants de crépy et de la région sont
décédés brûlé dans deux autocars qui
emmenait ses enfants dans le sud
je vous dis tout ça pour vous situer le
contexte du crédit qui reste aujourd'hui
avec les habitants avec tout ce qui nous
est arrivé est un contexte très
particulier
crépy en valois
cela reste un drame terrible terrible
donc je rappelle cet accident de beaune
et lui en 83 j'ai fait la promesse aux
parents de toujours et ravet que le jour
des commémorations chaque 31 juillet
crépy en valois c'est aussi la ville où
le 20 novembre 1981 un collège pailleron
a brûlé entièrement c'est le collège
jean de la fontaine où enseignait
monsieur dominique varotto le 8 juillet
les frères coup achi sont passés à crépy
en valois qui sera pendant une journée
complète en état de siège avec le gign
et le raid comme compagnon j'ai moi même
passé la nuit devant en voiture avec la
photo de ces deux fous en juin 2019
pollution de notre étang djerem situé
dans un magnifique parc de 21 hectares
avec 6000 litres de shampoing concentrer
le 21 juin 2019 effondrement d'une
partie
de notre collégiale saint thomas 300
tonnes monuments classés en 1875 et
maintenant le coc vide avec le premier
mort français
le premier de france atteint par cette
cochonnerie cela pour vous dire que
crépy en valois ne souhaite pas être le
centre de la presse nationale
car c'était déjà le cas et a subit son
lot de catastrophes ainsi que les
habitants qui restent fiers de leur
commune
crépy en valois reste un endroit
splendide calme reposant nous voudrions
maintenant un peu de calme mais
l'histoire reste l'histoire
voilà les deux l'étroit passage que je
voulais vous lire avant de répondre à
l'ensemble de vos questions et
effectivement un crépi ça a été un
moment difficile
nous avons eu des décès pas autant que
dans certaines communes mais ramené à la
proportion de notre commune c'était
important on a en gros malheureusement
doubler le nombre de décès entre 2019 et
2020 pendant cette période je n'ai
jamais voulu donner le nombre des décès
et comme je me dois de répondre à la
question puisque vous ne l'avez posé je
lui répondrais mais je n'ai jamais voulu
donner le nombre de décès on était en
période électorale
les opposants voulaient absolument
savoir et j'ai considéré qu'il y avait
pas lieu de donner ce chiffre qui
n'apportait rien à personne et je suis
resté muet sur ce sujet voilà je
répondrai ensuite à vos questions merci
merci monsieur le maire pour ce
témoignage très émouvant
ainsi madame la directrice
à vous pour cet exercice concret dans le
temps donc l'hôpital de crépy en valois
se situe à la frontière du sanitaire
puisque nous avons une autorisation de
30 lits de soins de suite et de
réadaptation et du médico social avec 30
lits de soins longue durée et 179 lits
d'ehpad
cette capacité totale de 239 lit et
répartis sur trois sites
l'hôpital saint lazare qui regroupe donc
le service de ssr le service du sld et
des lits d'ehpad les pales etienne marie
de la honte juste en face qui comporte
80 lits il n'est pas de les primevères
qui dispose de 88 lits dont 30 lits en
unité protégée pour les résidents
atteints de la maladie d'alzheimer ou
troubles apparentés
l'établissement dispose de 170 e tp
médicaux et non médicaux
nous faisons partie du groupement
hospitalier de territoire oise nord-est
et l'établissement support et le centre
hospitalier compiègne noyon si vous me
le permettez je préciserai l'ensemble
des autres éléments au fur et à mesure
des questions merci pour cette
présentation madame la directrice de ce
professeur
c'est le président messieurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
donc je m'appelle arnaud fontanet je
travaille l'institut pasteur
je suis directeur du département de
santé global directeur d'une unité de
recherche en maladies infectieuses
émergentes et je suis également membre
du conseil scientifique aux villes 19
pour mes compétences en épidémiologie
des notamment décoré d'un virus puisque
j'ai travaillé dans le passé sur le
corps d'un virus du sras ce en chine
puis du maire ce pays du golfe et france
est maintenant plus récemment sur ce
nouveau grands navires us sarre skov 2
donc mon application autour du
département de l'oise a débuté avec une
lettre du directeur général de la santé
datée du 2 mars qui me demandait en
qualité de chercheur à l'institut
pasteur de mener une enquête dans le
département de l'oise où on savait que
le virus circule est activement en
utilisant un test sérologique était
développée à l'institut pasteur
en fait plusieurs tests nous étions
parmi les premiers instituts en france à
être en mesure de développer ces tests
sérologiques et donc être capable de
dépister des anticorps qui permettait de
savoir si les personnes ont été
infectées ou non dans le passé ce qui
est un outil extrêmement important à la
fois à titre diagnostic mais plutôt
rétrospective mais surtout pour ses
fameuses enquêtes épidémiologiques qui
nous permettent de savoir quelle était
l'étendue de la première vague
épidémique notamment et donc j'ai à ce
moment là
le diagral la santé m'a suggéré de
travailler à crépy-en-valois notamment
autour du collège et du lycée où on
savait que le virus avait récemment
circulé activement on était le 2 mars
j'ai pris contact rapidement avec le
directeur de la rs monsieur etienne
champions et nous avons mis en place
avec le professeur bruno une qui est
directeur de recherche médicale annonce
du pasteur un premier protocole de
recherche mais qui a été monté en trois
jours pour pouvoir intervenir les 5 et 6
mars dans le collège et le lycée afin de
d'une part faire des dépistages de forme
active de l'affection parce que même si
c'était pas l'objet de notre recherche
il n'était pas pour nous pensable
d'aller sur place pour faire des
prélèvements sanguins sens en même temps
assurer une activité diagnostics pour
permettre l'identification des personnes
qui étaient activement infectées par le
virus et donc devaient être isolés pour
protéger les autres et puis être prise
en charge également médicalement
donc nous avons effectué en parallèle de
notre activité de recherche des
prélèvements chez des personnes
symptomatique qui nous ont permis
d'identifier 13 sur 90 testées étant
activement affectée nous avons transmis
immédiatement les résultats la rs pour
qu'elle puisse prendre toutes les
mesures d'isolement pour ses personnels
prise en charge médicale et en parallèle
nous avons prélevé toutes les personnes
qui avaient été symptomatique depuis la
mi janvier qui était la date présumée de
l'infection fat pardon du début de
l'épidémie sans qu'on ait de détails là
dessus mais on savait que des premières
personnes symptomatique avait été
clairement identifiés début février donc
on se disait que le virus avait pu
circuler dans la dernière quinzaine de
janvier
et les prélèvements qui ont été
réalisées à cette occasion nous ont
permis effectivement avec d'autres
paiements qui ont été réalisés dans le
cadre d'études dans les hôpitaux de
france et ailleurs de mettre au point de
tests sérologiques qui d'ailleurs sont
maintenant très performant puisqu'on a
des tests qui sont capables de détecter
avec beaucoup de fiabilité la présence
d'anticorps et est donc cette première
étude a rempli ses objectifs
quand on a vu l'intensité de la
circulation du virus dans cette période
du 5 6 mars nous étions à
crépy-en-valois nous avons repris
contact cette fois ci avec monsieur
bruno fortier qui nous a ouvert les
portes de crépy en valois
il nous a beaucoup soutenus pour la
suite des enquêtes que nous avons pu
mener d'abord entre le 30 mars et le 4
avril dans le lycée de crépy en valois
où nous avons invité les lycéens des
enseignants des personnels non
enseignants et comme les lycéens étaient
mineures on leur demandait d'être
accompagnés d'un parent et
éventuellement d'un proche si vous
voulez faire tester quelqu'un et nous
avons un cyprès alizés une première
enquête sur près de 700 personnes qui
nous a permis de documenter
effectivement une circulation très
active du virus dans le lycée dans les
quinze premiers jours de février
circulation qui a été stoppé par les
vacances scolaires qui a légèrement
repris puis définitivement stoppée avec
le confinement le 1er mars est un mois
plus tard nous sommes valait donc entre
le 28 mars et le 30 avril
répétez cette même opération cette fois
ci dans les écoles primaires
six écoles primaires de crépy en valois
pour voir si le virus avait circulé de
la même façon dans les écoles avec
l'idée une fois de plus de documenter la
circulation du virus dans cet
environnement mais également toutes les
questions que vous connaissez qui se
posaient sur la circulation du virus
dans des écoles et à différents âges
puisque se pose évidemment la question
de la réouverture des écoles à la
rentrée et que ce type de données
pouvait être extrêmement informative il
se trouve que l'ensemble de ces études a
été
très riche d'enseignements et je pourrai
revenir sur les résultats pour les uns
et des autres si vous voulez avoir les
détails
nous avons communiqué les résultats sous
forme de webinars avec la population à
deux reprises c'est à dire que avec
grâce à l'aide de monsieur bruno fortier
nous avons pu faire c'est webinar en
ligne pour pouvoir transmettre les
résultats à la communauté avant qu'elle
ne l'apprenne par les journaux parce
qu'on pensait que c'était pour les
personnes les participants préférable
qu'ils connaissent les résultats globaux
j'entends sans la prendre par la presse
mais directement par nous et on a pu
répondre à leurs questions et
immédiatement après une communication
plus générale été fait avec la presse
sur les résultats de ces études et on a
rendu les résultats individuellement
toutes les personnes qui le souhaitaient
donc il ya on a mis en place tout un
système une fois de plus avec l'aide de
monsieur bruno fortier de la directrice
des établissements scolaires de la
rectrice damien on a vraiment eu et puis
monsieur etienne champions aussi est
intervenu plusieurs fois pour une
facilité la tâche
grâce au soutien de ces personnes on a
pu avoir à la fois des contacts
individuels avec les personnes pour leur
rendre le résultat mais aussi elle a
passé précisé le communiqué plus
généralement ce que je voudrais dire
juste pour conclure c'est que ma grande
fierté ça a été de pouvoir aux côtés de
monsieur bruno fortier de monsieur
etienne champions et de tous les acteurs
locaux permettre à la population de
crépy en valois qui a été très meurtrie
par cette épidémie comme monsieur le
maire nous le rappeler de participer
activement une recherche qui a je le
pense
eu un impact considérable non seulement
à l'échelon local mais également
nationale et même internationale pour la
petite histoire j'ai la semaine dernière
donnait des interviews au wall street
jounal new york times washington post je
suis passé sur cnn sur cbs news sur les
résultats crépy en valois monsieur le
maire je vous enverrai ses interviews
parce que ces résultats publiés à
l'international sont parmi les toutes
premières études qui nous donne des
informations sur les lycéens et sur les
enfants d'écoles primaires et le risque
d'être affecté dans ces environnements
donc c'est pour vous dire et je tiens
encore une fois de plus monsieur maire
vous remercier que votre
contribution nous a permis d'une part de
répondre à quelques questions localement
mais une fois de plus grâce à la
participation de toutes les personnes de
la mairie et de la municipalité de
répondre à des questions qui sont
d'importance capitale face à cette
terrible épidémie à l'échelle mondiale
je vous remercie
merci nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
à travers les questions
un monsieur fort oui a simplement un mot
pour rapporter ce que ce que le
professeur nous dit effectivement à la
suite de ce qui nous est arrivé sur
crépy je vous rappelle qu'un choix avant
tout le monde toute la mairie était
confiné g confiné monsieur le préfet
monsieur le sous préfet monsieur le
député voilà à cause d'eux à cause de
moi si je puis dire mais bon et l'image
de crépy était terrible nous avons entre
2000 et 3000 personnes qui prennent le
train tous les matins on est à 35
minutes de la gare du nord dès le
premier jour de l'annoncé de la mort de
ce pauvre monsieur varotto les nos
employeurs téléphonez à leurs employés
pour dire ne venez pas vous êtes de
crépy en valois ou ne venez pas vous
êtes de l'oise je leur faut bien se
rendre compte de ça quinze jours avant
tout le monde
et l'image de crépy était terriblement
détériorer et ça je supporte pas nous
l'avons donc gg est demandée l'institut
pasteur
le professeur et puis monsieur bruno
voyer je me suis trompé
voilà ma dit peut-être qu'on pourrait
donner une autre image en faisant en
sorte que des tests soient faits sur ce
répit puisque c'était le premier lieu de
condamner une comptabilisation et
peut-être que l'image de crépy pour
échanger pour l'avenir et donner une
image de recherche sur cette cochonnerie
et j'ai dit j'ai dit oui et j'ai dit on
continue et on y va encore et il y aura
peut-être des suites
le professeur pourra vous le dire tout à
l'heure merci merci monsieur le maire la
parole à madame à l'heure à porter
catherine des roches
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président merci à tous
pour vos témoignages en effet vous dire
combien on partage ce qu'a dû être là
les difficultés et la douleur de de
votre département
et vous monsieur le maire on a bien
senti à travers votre témoignage aussi
la place importante qui a été celle des
élus locaux et des mères en particulier
qui sont vraiment au coeur de leurs
populations qui sont avec leurs
habitants et qui souffre comme leurs
habitants et donc merci pour ce
témoignage et pour tout ce que vous avez
fait durant cette période
moi j'avais une première question vous
nous avez dit monsieur le directeur de
la r est ce que finalement dès le 23
janvier vous aviez des instructions sur
ce qu'était en effet cette épidémie qui
se préparait donc je voudrais savoir ce
que vous avez mis en place dès le 1er
janvier quels ont été les instructions
qui vous ont deux étaient donnés par le
par le niveau national comment se sont
fait justement les liens entre ce que
vous viviez vous de façon très locale
dans l'oise on l'a vu dans le grand test
on l'a vu dans la région parisienne et
comment se faisait les allers retours
entre l'échelon très local et l'échelon
national parce que vous nous dites
monsieur fontanet qu' il y avait en
effet ce foyer et ce virus qui circule
de façon active à crépy en valois et
dans d'autres communes de l'oise en
février et fin février et début mars et
en même temps au niveau national on nous
incitait le 6 mars à les assortir à
l'eau restaurant aller au cinéma et dans
les théâtres
est-ce que là on était sur une immunité
une recherche d' immunité collective
pourquoi pas je dis aime ça nous a
jamais été présenté comme tel donc je
laisse à voir vraiment ce décalage
comment vous l'expliquez et comment vous
avez pu pallier
il y avait aussi beaucoup de questions
qui se sont posées sur la base de la
base aérienne de creil sûrement si vous
pouvez peut-être peut-être plus vous
monsieur le préfet parce que beaucoup
d'informations peut-être fausse ont
circulé mais comment vraiment la réalité
s'est faite au niveau de deux militaires
de creil qui était qui rentrait de chine
ça c'est le premier point
quelle a été la place aussi de santé
publique france c'est ça c'est ptet plus
monsieur le recteur de la rs qui
pourrait nous dire comment ont été les
relations entre santé publique france le
dernier point bon les protections les
masses que vous avez bien expliqué
madame la présidente
les difficultés rencontrées les tests le
premier patient celui que vous appelez
le numéro un dans 20 départements
avaient été testés dès le départ
lorsqu'il a eu les premiers symptômes
patients qu'il est décédé
oui enfin quels tests lui avait été
pratiquée dès le départ
et puis lorsque lorsque vous l'avez bien
dit monsieur le maire les habitants
crépy en valois devait se rendre quelque
part et prenait de transport en commun
les équipements étaient suffisants pour
qu'il prenne les consignes et les gestes
barrière avait été bien bien défini et
puis un tout dernier point c'est sur le
pilotage vous l'avez évoqué madame là la
présidente
ça nous a souvent été relaté c'est elle
cette dualité puis le tage entre les
services de l'état le préfet mais aussi
la rs et le côté sanitaire est ce que
vous vous avez vécu ce double pilotage
de façon correcte ou où ça a été un
frein ou ça vous a présenté difficulté
on a l'impression que selon les
départements ça a été très variable
parfois ça s'est très bien passé parfois
c'était plus compliqué et quelle a été
la place de la direction territoriale de
l'oise de la rs au milieu de mille
lieues de ce pilotage
merci alors des questions qu'ils sont
ce qui s'adressent à différents
interlocuteurs nous commençons par celle
qui concerne monsieur le directeur de la
rs1 la place de santé publie france ou
bien les décalages et cetera circulation
du virus ça désigne sub directeur madame
la rapporteure alors effectivement avec
à partir du 23 janvier nous commençons à
nous préparer nous avons reçu au courant
du mois de janvier
ce qu'on appelle dans notre jargon indé
minsante c'est à dire les mails et les
messages qui passe par ou électronique
évidemment qui sont des instructions ou
des informations du ministère de la
santé généralement signé par le
directeur général de la santé et
notamment qui au départ était sur les
questions internationales bien entendu
mais qui était aussi sur l'évolution 1,2
de l'épidémie dans le monde parce que
c'était pas purement théorique
évidemment c'est ce qu'on définisse elle
ce qu'on appelle donc la définition de
cas la définition de cas c'est à la fois
une question clinique
1 parce qu'évidemment il fallait qu
ensuite ont pu discuter avec les
médecins de du périmètre clinique du
patient et puis aussi une définition
géographique un au départ rue anne puis
le hebei et c'est la chine enfin bon et
donc tout ça évidemment fait partie des
éléments
par ailleurs nous avons eu notamment à
toute fin du mois de janvier une
première réunion ensuite très clairement
le pilotage national avec nous c'est une
vision quotidienne
tous les soirs à 20h président et
suivant les moments par le directeur
général de la santé ou par le directeur
de cabinet du préfet j'insiste sur ce
point parce que c'est extrêmement
important
il faudrait que je vais je vais jouer je
vais chercher je vais vous le je vais
vous la trouvez mais ce ça va assez vite
ans en tout cas il ya des premières
visions et puis ensuite elle devient
vraiment quotidien je je je je je vous
donnerai la date exacte pour moi ce
système il est extrêmement important
parce que dès la fin janvier puis
ensuite le mois de février puis
évidemment ensuite et ça devient
vraiment quotidien nous avons en fait
une chaîne de réactivité extrêmement
forte sur l'ensemble du territoire de la
région
tous les jours il ya une cellule de
crise dans chacun des établissements
tous les jours nous avons une audio avec
l'ensemble de les principaux
établissements une fois sur deux avec
l'ensemble des établissements parce
qu'évidemment les impliquer son de
manière croissante dans le temps et tous
les jours nous avons notre vision
nationale ce qui veut dire qu'à la
limite un problème évoqué dans une
cellule de crise d'un établissement le
matin il peut être réglé le soir ça
c'est essentiel et j'ai toujours tenu à
ça et une fois de plus je voudrais
vraiment le dire je l' ai dit en
introduction
pour moi ça ne il n'y a pas de sens à
cette voyez ce que je veux dire on est
dans une boucle cette boucle
elle va dans les deux sens moi je très
franchement 1 et si j'ai organisé des
conférences audio très tôt en janvier à
la fois d'ailleurs avec par exemple les
chefs de sa mue qui sont nos experts de
la gestion de crise et les
infectiologues et notamment le
professeur schmidt au chu d'amiens
la professeure fort au chu de lille
c'est que pour moi la rsl ne peut pas
avoir tout l' expertise elle est là pour
articuler et ses conférences c'était
tout autant des conférences de consensus
que de passage d d d d d d éléments que
je pouvais avoir du national ce point il
est pour moi essentiel
on n'est pas dans du descendant ni même
seulement dans de l'ascendant on est
justement dans ce système et à partir du
moment où vous avez toute la chaîne tous
les jours
eh bien on peut aller très vite et ça je
avec monsieur préfet nous avions la
visite de
madame de montchanin lundi ou à
l'hôpital de beauvais ça nous a été très
bien décrit c'est pour ça que je me
permets de leur décrire aujourd'hui par
ailleurs avec l'ensemble des autres
acteurs les ehpad les professionnels de
santé via notamment les ordres les u r
ps nous avons eu le même logique d'avoir
ce système et moi pour moi les
expertises
elle vient tout autant du terrain que
évidemment de du national et par
ailleurs nous avions l'ensemble des
organisations avec les élus dont nous
avons parlé tout à l'heure sur santé
publique france alors santé publique
france à un nombre varié de deux
missions nous avons bien sûr comme vous
le savez au sein de l' ars va pas au
salaire est hébergé par la rs mais avec
nous des équipes de qu'on appelle la sir
la cellule régionale qui à la fois à des
missions épidémiologique
c'est elle qui fait toutes les données
qu'il et remonte et c'est aussi une
participation au travail du tracé oulaï
en fait un travail commun entre les
équipes de veille sanitaire de la rs et
hélas si on est dans une équipe quasi
commune qui travaillent ensemble je
voudrais dire une chose quand même qui
est important que je pense parce que je
trouve que dans les médias il ya des
choses qui à chaque fois meurt ça n'est
pas vrai que les ars n'ont pas l'accès
curité sanitaires comme au coeur de leur
mission je voudrais juste dire une chose
c'est que la direction de la sécurité
sanitaire et de la santé
environnementale
c'est la première direction de la rs
hauts de france en nombre et je peux
vous dire moi je ne suis arrivé qu'en
septembre dernier
je peux vous dire que quand une cellule
de crise se met en place à la rs 2 août
france le directeur général n'a même pas
besoin de regarder ça se met en place
tout seul et la culture de la gestion de
crise je peux vous garantir
nous avons eu lubrizol en septembre même
si on a pas moins parler de nous parce
que évidemment nous étions dans le
panache mais de manière évidemment
beaucoup moins forte que heureusement
nous avons eu évidemment le coc vide
cette culture elle est très forte santé
publique france s'occupe donc des
données elle s'occupera notamment
des données des ehpad qui ont qui est de
l'agrégation nous n'avons pas géré ce
domaine elle gère aussi évidemment mais
ça de manière descendante toute une
série de questions sur sur les masques
je reviens du coup sûr les masques sur
les masques je voudrais dire des choses
très précises parce que en fait je sais
bien que vous vous le savez mais je le
dis quand même parce que c'est important
les ars n'ont pas été chargé de la
logistique des masques je sais que vous
le savez mais je prêt que je veux le
dire publiquement parce qu'il ya de la
confusion y compris par des acteurs
parce que comme la rs et d'un est un
interlocuteur quand il ya des problèmes
on appelle la rs et c'est très bien mais
bon il y a deux flux d air s d es
démasqué il y a le flux dit j'ai acheté
avec un transporteur privé qui tout au
long de la période a distribués
essentiellement aux établissements
médico sociaux mais aussi avant tout
sanitaires en passant justement parlé
j'ai acheté cette distribution est aussi
pas pour les services ensuite pour les
services à domicile ça c'est le premier
mot là dessus les ars n'ont fait qu'une
chose
elle avait les fichiers elle vérifiait
qu'est pas de problème et elle pouvait
remonter des problèmes s'ils avaient des
difficultés mais ce n'est pas une
gestion par les ars
ensuite deuxième flux le flux officines
essentiellement pour les professionnels
de santé de ville
ce flux est là encore totalement
nationale un premier la première
livraison le 18 mars par geodis ensuite
par le système classique des grossistes
répartiteurs qui est vraiment le système
de distribution normale c'est là encore
une logistique nationale et donc là les
ars n'interviennent pas du tout
cependant les ars ont évidemment
souhaité comme d'ailleurs l'ont fait de
manière volontaire les collectivités
territoriales nous avons voulu aider
sur ce point nous avons donc notamment
nous ne sommes pas les seuls d'ailleurs
un mais nous avons sur la base
des dons que nous avons pu récupérer
nous avons pu faire des distributions je
vous donne juste une idée des chiffres
un très tôt nous avons distribué dans
l'oise trente-deux mille masques ou
établissements médico-sociaux 1 dès le
mois de mars très beau début de la crise
nous avons fait dix milles sur les ca
des laisses yade ensuite globalement sur
la période
juste pour avoir une idée de l'ordre de
grandeur nous avons fait une une chaîne
de dons qui nous a permis de distribuer
500 mille masques sur sur l'oise mais
c'est à comparer à des chiffres beaucoup
plus élevés d'éditer des chaînes
nationales 4,5 millions pour les j'ai
acheté et 2,9 millions pour les
officiers nous avons été là pour
remonter à se rendre les difficultés
mais une fois de plus nous n'étions pas
en charge de cette de 7,2 cette fonction
sur les tests alors la question était
précise n'était sûr monsieur varotto en
fait il a été testé tardivement puisque
comme je l'expliquais il ne
correspondait absolument pas à la
définition de cas et donc les médecins 1
n'avait pas envisagé sa situation
puisqu'il ne revenait pas un et
d'ailleurs les épidémiologistes ont
quand même mis fin d'ailleurs les choses
n'est pas encore totalement établi le
lien il n'y a aucun non seulement il
n'est pas ben ils n'avaient pas voyagé
mais il n'était pas en lien avec
quelqu'un qui revenait de chine à
l'époque on est vraiment dans une
épidémie chinoise alors sur la question
peut-être je suis parent évidemment le
seul à pouvoir m'exprimer là-dessus mais
je vais quand même donner mon opinion
sur sur la dualité de pilotage on peut
dire dualité le préfet a dit duo
il a même dit triaud moi je je parle de
mon expérience j'en parle pour l'oise
mais je crois aussi que je pourrais je
pense que
louis le franc pourrait en témoigner
parce qu'on a eu beaucoup de contacts je
crois que le travail s'est fait vraiment
en coordination toujours avec les
préfets avec les élus je crois pas
qu'ils aient eu de dualité au sens on
peut l'entendre cette radio ce n'est pas
un duel très clairement et moi je je
retiens d'une expérience très forte
d'une intégration d'intégration
permanente chacun apportant son
expérience chacun sa compétence sur
l'ensemble des sujets on peut parler
peut-être juste janvier un mot puisque
ça a été évoqué par madame la présidente
le sujet de là pour le coup de la double
tutelle sur les ehpad c'est un vrai
sujet
juste une chose et c'est vrai que ça
introduit une sorte de complexité nous
ce que nous souhaitons toujours et nous
essayons au maximum nos services parle
en permanence et on essaye de minimiser
ce problème du point de vue des
établissements je crois qu'il faut mieux
s'articuler toujours mieux
je pense quand même un point qui est
important c'est que ce que montre aussi
cette crise c'est que l'imbrication
sanitaire médico-social l'apport du
sanitaire dans les ehpad et du maire
génération médico social a été
fondamental pour la prise en charge de
deux c'est toujours vrai mais toutes les
logiques de filière gériatrique
tout ça c'est essentiel et donc je sais
double tutelle elle est évidemment un
peu complexe mais elle marque aussi un
ancrage local très important il s'avère
que j'ai été pendant cinq ans directeur
général adjoint des services d'un
département gros des partout où j'ai une
conne je je connais bien et je pour moi
il n'y a pas du tout pour le coup encore
de dualité entre collectivités
territoriales et état on peut toujours
mieux travailler mais je pense que le
lien avec le sanitaire est quelque chose
de très important et juste pour répondre
sur et j'aurai fini désolé devrait être
un peu long il y avait beaucoup de
questions et je souhaite être précis la
directrice départementale de l'oise bien
sûr a toujours été présente
elle était là depuis le début elle
continue elle est en permanence auprès
du du du préfet avec les élus on à la
permanence participer moi même je me
suis rendu sur place
au tout début quasiment pendant les tout
prochains jours j'étais sur place tous
les jours
pour pouvoir vraiment être au plus près
par ailleurs je voulais dire aussi en
termes de renforcement par exemple nous
avons renforcé les équipes de la rs sur
place et par exemple directeur adjoint
de l'offre médico social parce que tout
de suite un dès le premier jour nous
avons perçu cet important du milieu
social le directeur adjoint de la
direction régionale est venu s'installer
dans l'oise
pendant plusieurs plusieurs jours dans
tout le moment des dépistages pour
renforcer notre approche locale
monsieur le préfet du haut du alité trio
monsieur le président côté petit nous je
vais rebondir sur ce qui vient d'être
dit par étienne champion directeur gère
le rs on a pratiqué dans l'oise
notamment dès le premier mois une forme
d'interministérialité local des
concentrés de dire on n'a pas entendu
que tout tombe des niveaux des étages
supérieurs on a pris notre sort en main
et avec le directeur général de la rs et
la rectrice d'académie dernière
puisqu'ils ont compétence directe sur
les problématiques hospitalière
établissements médico-sociaux
établissements scolaires était évident
quand on s'inscrit d'emblée dans une
logique de complémentarité
voilà il n'y avait pas d'autre solution
va raconter vous avez insisté sur
l'importance du maire et le dire est que
le maire est a été un élément central
dans la gestion de la pandémie dans
département de l'oise centrale alors
j'avais si je puis dire le petit
avantage d'être presque depuis on poste
depuis presque trois ans je ne dis pas
que je connais des 680 maires des
départements personnellement mais j'en
connais comme un grand nombre et je
pense que la relation interpersonnelle
que le préfet peut avoir avec le maire
alors c'est l'avantagé à dire de
situation que le préfet un préfet de
département peut avoir par rapport à un
directeur général de rs qui rayonne sur
l'ensemble de la région ou une rectrice
d'académie qui forcément ne peut pas
connaître les élus comme le préfet et
donc c'est cette qualité de relation a
été déterminante des relations confiance
c'est moi j'étais dans une situation où
il a fallu en l'absence de mesures
nationales prendre des décisions locales
alors j'ai partagé évidemment
avec le responsable sanitaire et le
responsable académique mais je les fais
aussi avec le président du conseil
départemental qui rayonne sur l'ensemble
du département
même si la sorte son champ de compétence
est très important d'avoir cet échange
avec elle avec l'union des maires de
l'oise avec les présidents des trois
agglomérations du département d'avoir
cet échange pour pouvoir justement faire
accepter ces mesures qu'elle ait des
mesures coercitives
moi j'étais amené dès le départ en sus
le président à interdire tout
rassemblement dans le département pour
justement éviter que le virus se propage
vers la partie ouest du département
puisqu'ils étaient concentrées dans le
quart sud-est voilà ce que j'étais amené
à faire de la même manière des marchés
il ya beaucoup de marchés dans le
département qui fonctionne et il ya
beaucoup de communes rurales et ma
présidente qui est très attaché un
défense des communes rurales fort raison
d'ailleurs ce avec en interdisant les
marchés qui étaient des lieux de
rassemblement sur lesquels étaient des
foyers de contamination potentielle
eh bien j'ai interdit que ces marchés se
tiennent en l'absence de toute directive
nationale voilà ce que j'ai fait je
l'expliqué mais je n'ai pas pu le faire
lire de façon trop longue
parce que on entrait dans une
problématique notamment pour les
producteurs agroalimentaires de survie
tout simplement et pour les
consommateurs dans des communes isolées
en milieu rural donc il a fallu
progressivement desserré l'étau voilà ce
que j'étais amené à faire et donc c'est
de relations avec le maire on a beaucoup
parlé du coup le préfet maire mais elle
est fondamentale fondamental dans la
gestion d'une pandémie
c'est essentiel pour vous répondre à la
rapporteur sur la base de créer la base
de creil a été considéré un petit peu
trop vite d'ailleurs comme le foyer de
propagation du virus en france il ya eu
cette fameuse première mission le 31
janvier depuis l'aéroport de wuhan qui
tout de suite à jeter une forme de
discrédit sur la base aérienne de creil
heureusement l'institut pasteur
remercie a permis d'écarter cette piste
mais pas tout de suite puisque le virus
a muté six fois c'est comme ça ça nous a
été présenté sur monsieur jean pierre
gross a requis et le personnel civil qui
a fait l'objet donc d'une
hospitalisation un premier temps à
compiègne et un transfert ensuite aussi
à chu d'amiens dans les sorties
d'ailleurs malheureusement pour lui très
diminuée bon ça a été écartée cette
suspicion mais pas tout de suite écarté
scientifiquement pour autant ça a été
difficile à vivre pour le maire de creil
pour le pied aussi de président de
l'agglomération de cry parce qu'il se
trouve que la base aérienne de creil
l'origine du cluster de creil finalement
c'était la base aérienne de creil
c'est aussi pour ça que creil à une
clijsters mais il n'était pas évidemment
démontré que la base était base aérienne
de creil était le sens à partir duquel
circulaient ce virus pour autant il ya
toute une série de mesures qui ont été
prises le commandant de la base de creil
que vous auditionnerait peut-être je ne
sais pas moi il m'a informé
régulièrement des évolutions de la
situation sanitaire
il m'a fait le point du nombre de
malades
je lui ai demandé leur état du nombre de
cas confirmés du nombre de cas probables
du nombre de cas guéri du nombre de
personnels placés en confinement to sign
é me l'a dit ou pas oui je vous les
donnerais je vous les donnerais sans
difficulté j'ai tous les messages qu'il
m'a communiqué par écrit et je vous
dirai très précisément ce qu'il en est
des informations qui demandent
communiqué j'en avait impérativement
besoin puisque des personnels il ya 3000
personnes qui travaillent sur la base
aérienne de creil
une partie d'entre elles sont domiciliés
en ile de france
une autre partie est domicilié dans le
département de l'oise moi j'avais
impérativement besoin de savoir qu'ils
étaient contaminés ou ces petits bouts
de l'être pour justement éviter à
l'occasion donc
de la période de l'ouverture des écoles
que les parents d'enfants ne se rende
pas dans des écoles eux-mêmes et en
compte étant contaminée ou
potentiellement j'ai besoin que les
maires le sache ce qui a été fait donc
j'ai demandé au colonel commandant la
base d'informer les maires on a redoublé
à notre niveau effectué re voyez voilà
chez vous vous avez trois ou quatre
personnes que vous connaissez qui
travaillaient qui travaille sur la base
personnes à des enfants donc la consigne
qui leur est donné c'est confinement il
ne bouge pas ne sortent pas de leur
domicile et n'amène surtout pas leurs
enfants à l'école bah ça c'est la
relation que j'ai eue avec le colonel
comment la base et avec des maires dans
cette information ils mangent les
partager avec de directeur général de la
rs il ya le service de santé des armées
donc ses services de santé des armées
qui opérait au sein de la base de creil
moi je n'avais pas connaître de quelle
façon série de santé désormais opérer
dans sa méthode ses modes d'action sur
la base mais par contre je connaissais
le résultat et c'était fondamental pour
moi de justement de connaître ces
informations pour que les mères encore
une fois ayant des personnels de la base
dans leur commune sache exactement où on
en est quelles sont les mesures prises
et quelles sont les perspectives
donc tout ça ça a été véritablement
appréhender de manière globale pour le
directeur de général de rs les
informations qui ont été communiquées
je les ai transmises ainsi qu'au préfet
de région qui se trouve dans l'est une
france est aussi le préfet de zone dont
il y avait une remontée d'informations
sur la situation de la base aérienne de
creil
malheureusement comme je vous l ai dit
tout à l'heure cette suspicion qui
pesait sur sur la base n'a pas facilité
les choses
alors c'est une base aérienne s'est pas
c'est pas à moulins vont voir
il ya des activités qui n'ont pas je
dire à être mise sur la place publique
donc ces activités qui ont duré du
secret pour autant sur le plan sanitaire
moi j'ai eu les informations dont
j'avais besoin pour que les maires d où
il y avait des personnels concernés
sache exactement où on en était et
comment la situation évolue et moi ce
que je peux vous dire maman portait
ainsi les élus locaux souhaitent
importer madame la présidente
le rapporteur
moi je reviens quand même sur sur les
masques même si effectivement la rs ne
vais pas ce rôle mais néanmoins nous le
seul interlocuteur que nous avions
c'était la grèce n'avait pas d'autres
interlocuteurs
concernant les masques et s'il est vrai
que tout a été mis en place rapidement
pour les hôpitaux
ça n'a pas été le cas pour les autres
mais parce qu'il n'y avait pas de masque
aussi il faut dire les choses telles que
et moi quand j'avais des personnes qui
travaillent dans les services
d'accompagnement à domicile qui me
disaient j'ai un masque chirurgical et
je le lave le soir à l'eau de javel
pouvoir leur mettre le lendemain coûté à
un moment ça me fait bondir quoi et
c'est là que le département commencent à
dire on doit acheter des masques
même si on nous dit aussi ac pas à vous
de le faire oui sauf que s'il y en a pas
on essaie par tous les moyens d'en avoir
pour essayer de parer à ces à ces
difficultés
donc les masques ça a été un problème
les ambulanciers n'avait pas de masque
après ils pouvaient soit allé dans l'est
dans les officines mais les officines
design on en a déjà pas assez pour les
médecins donc on peut pas donner on peut
pas donner aux ambulanciers ensuite il
devait aller dans les hôpitaux mais les
hôpitaux n'avaient pas non plus donc à
un moment il a fallu quand même trouver
des solutions locales pour que ces
personnes puissent faire leur travail
parce qu'elle elle devait travailler on
avait la même chose avec les taxis les
taxis conventionnés par la sécurité
sociale
il devait aussi intervenir puisque on
parle beaucoup effectivement du gyrus
mais il y avait aussi toutes les autres
pathologies est donc il fallait aussi
hospitalisé ou quelquefois porté à les
conduire les personnes pour le reçoit
donc c'était assez compliqué mais je
dirais le problème pour moi qui était le
plus important aussi c'est et les pompes
funèbres
personne n'avait pensé aux pompes
funèbres il a vraiment fallu au niveau
du département
et bien quand on se démène avec la
préfecture et notamment que le
sous-préfet de clermont qui est
téléchargé aussi de trouver des
solutions et que nous on a acheté des
masques aussi pour en donner
parce qu'à un moment les morgues et
aides étaient saturés il fallait trouver
des solutions et si un moment cette
profession nous disait mais nous si on
n'a pas de masque on va pas chercher les
corps on se retrouver dans des
situations hyper complexe donc tout le
monde a mis du sien et on a trouvé des
masques effectivement des entreprises
nous en ont donné on en a acheté enfin
voilà et puis ensuite les choses se sont
améliorées puisque y ait le plus de
masques tout cela pour combien de temps
il ya une pénurie de masques tombent
les premières sont les premières
semaines du manoir premières secondes on
y venait nous précisément en fonction le
voter quand je parle des réunions
régionales c'est les réunions que nous
avions en visioconférence deux fois par
semaine au début et ensuite on a eu une
fois par semaine avec tous les
départements
après arrivé à certains stades
effectivement on est au même niveau
malheureusement on avait autant de on
avait des décès enfin et c est dans la
première partie
là où le département de l'oise
enregistré malheureusement un nombre de
décès est important que ce soit à
l'hôpital que ce soit dans les ehpad à
ce moment là nous sommes le seul
département à vivre cette situation
est ce que moi je reproche c'est pas un
reproche un constat plutôt c'est de
faire des réunions tous ensemble alors
qu'un département est vraiment très
touchés c'était peut-être de faire un
point particulier sur ce département est
de passer la parole à tout le monde avec
le même temps de parole alors qu'on
n'avait pas les mêmes problèmes moi
c'est vraiment ce que ce que moi je
reproche maintenant on vient évidemment
au niveau de l'oise
monsieur le préfet l'a dit on on
s'appelait x fois dans la journée le
week-end et c'est pour faire face au fur
et à mesure monsieur champions nous
l'avions également au téléphone donc il
ya eu un vrai travail est une vraie
concertation entre nous mais néanmoins
on a vraiment vraiment été au début et
au début c'était vraiment un vrai
problème parce qu'ils n'avaient pas de
masse parce que tout se mettait en route
et ce n'était pas simple voilà c'était
ça ce que je voulais je voulais dire
et puis concernant la cotutelle bien la
cotutelle c'est pas simple
je le dis une fois de plus je pense que
s'il ya des choses à faire évoluer
c'est bien cette côte utelle je suis
ravi que monsieur le directeur de la rsr
en général de la rs partage le même
point de vue que moi merci vous n'êtes
pas les seuls à partager ce point de vue
monsieur le maire oui je voulais
apporter également sujet des masques des
informations moi je redescends au ras de
terre et ceux qui ont manqué des masses
ce sont les médecins les infirmières et
rupture éventuelle possible de l'hôpital
de la sagesse qui est un établissement
une maison de retraite pour handicapés
les dix ans et moi j'avais décidé qu'il
ne manquerai jamais de masques à crépy
en valois
chacun défend sa paroisse moi je devais
défendre ma paroisse je n'ai eu de cesse
d'appeler monsieur le préfet qui de
temps en temps passer son téléphone à
son directeur de cabinet parce qu'il
était en réunion et je l'appelais et je
dois vous dire que monsieur le préfet et
là c'est pas monsieur le préfet c'est
monsieur louis lefranc préfet de l'oise
qui a toujours répondu à mes demandes et
c'est pour moi extrêmement important
même si les masques avait des dates
périmés et ben on se débrouillait avec
ce qu'on avait juan demandait 1000
il m'en donnait cinq sens je faisais
avec j'organise à une réunion j'allais
moi même porter les masques chez les
médecins
ff les deux ffp3 jallet les infirmières
sont venus à mon bureau je les appelais
tout
une infirmière est venue elle pleurait
parce qu'elle n'avait plus de masques
voilà donc ça c'est pas lier forcément
si vous voulez à ce que vivent les
infirmières elles font tout un tas
d'autres choses mais pour travailler
vous n'avez rien donc voilà donc
franchement je j'attire votre attention
sur les masques au bout de la chaîne il
y en avait pas nous on se débrouillait
et on en a jamais manqué parce que parce
que on se débrouillait on a eu des dons
on a eu voilà la préfecture qui nous a
bien aidés et puis il n'ya pas que les
masques
la directrice de l'hôpital va peut-être
vous en parlait il ya ce qu'on a à moi
j'ai appris ça les blues et les
surblouse les tabliers
voilà les tabliers les charlottes j'en
avais donné ça allait encore mais les
blues une fois j'appelle monsieur le
préfet je vois là c'est pas des masques
aujourd'hui monsieur le préfet mais je
voudrais bien des blues les des blues
que jetables et me dit c'est pas aux
gens on va en trouver et il me rappelle
en me disant monsieur le maire on a
trouvé deux sens la sous-préfecture de
clairement deux sens merci monsieur le
préfet mais l'hôpital et la sagesse sont
utilisés
1500 pas par semaine vous voyez que donc
j'ai pris quand même ma voiture et je
vous raconterai j'ai fait une journée
pour vous présenter une journée d'un
maire dans cette période et je suis allé
à la sous-préfecture de clermont
dépoussiérer les cartons les mettre dans
la voiture et les ramener immédiatement
la sagesse qui à l'époque m'avait donné
200 masques que voyons fait des échanges
de troc de son masque que j'ai amené à
l'hôpital ensuite
donc voilà donc vraiment les les masques
aux aura du terrain au ras de terre
voilà il nous manquait des masques moi
j'ai tout fait pour qu ils ne manquent
pas mais c'était vraiment plus
qu'important on parle des hôpitaux on
parle des ehpad etc
mais les utilisateurs en manquait voilà
ce que je voulais apporter
merci madame la directrice en ce qui
concerne le premier passant et la
pénurie éventuellement des éléments de
protection
alors en ce qui concerne donc la la
pénurie de matériel de protection alors
l'hôpital de crespian vonn n'a jamais
été en pénurie s'il n'a jamais manqué de
matériel on a souvent été à flux tendu
mais on n'a jamais manqué le matin est
ce important de le préciser on a
toujours pu donner le matériel de
protection nécessaires aux personnels et
ensuite aux résidents alors
l'établissement possède un stock pour
lui permettre de faire face aux
épidémies hivernales
donc on avait déjà un stock on avait en
disposer de masques ffp2 et de masques
chirurgicaux la difficulté ça a été la
durée de la crise on avait un stock mais
qui était forcément pas suffisant pour
tous les semaines qui allait venir
pour autant on a pu faire donc dès le
début en fait de la crise pour nous dès
le 26 le 26 février
on a pu commander des équipements de
protection supplémentaire il en restait
encore chez certains fournisseurs
donc on à reconstituer des stocks pour
sécuriser justement l'approvisionnement
au sein d'établissements et puis au fur
et à mesure au tout début de la crise on
a demandé
à la rs d'être livré en masques ffp2 et
donc ils ont livré de deux mille masques
ffp2 donc dès le lundi la volonté du
samedi et on a aussi délivré à nouveau
de masques chirurgicaux cinq mille
masques chirurgicaux par la rs également
ensuite on a pu bénéficier aussi de dons
donc via la gendarmerie puisqu'il y
avait des des entreprises des
particuliers qui faisait des dons et
donc c'est la gendarmerie qui régulait
ces dons et qui nous transmettait après
le matériel dont on avait éventuellement
besoin est évidemment les venues très
régulière de monsieur le maire pour nous
livrer justement le fameux les fameux
matériel de protection dont il vient de
parler merci en ce qui concerne le
premier cas il est passé dans votre
hôpital
le test qui n'a pas été effectué sur
vennant très bien oui juste un point
avant de parler peut-être où je bois sa
parole après parce que il ya une
question très pertinente de d'habitude
de catherine déroché en ce qui
concernait et les insertions la
circulation du virus est et l'éventuelle
temps où on a peut-être envisager une
immunité collective en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on a parfois ressenti alors j'ai
juste donné quelques éléments de
chronologie par rapport à l'épidémie en
france qui sont importants on a d'abord
eu six introductions avec des personnes
qui arrivait de chine du 24 au 30
janvier entre paris et bordeaux
et puis tous les contacts ont été testés
personnes étaient affectées tout est
rentré dans l'ordre
il ya eu ensuite l'épisode et
contaminent vie février six personnes
affectées contact tester tout le monde
est négatif
tout est rentré dans l'ordre et là on a
eu une période pour moi très étrange
alors j'étais chercheur à l'institut
pasteur je n'ai aucune fonction à
l'époque mais je suivais cette épidémie
évidemment qui m'intéressait et du 8 au
25 février
il se passait rien il n'y avait aucune
circulation connues du virus sur le
territoire français on voyait bien que
en asie du sud-est en asie pardon plus
généralement la chine mais quelques pays
autour sa circulaire on a vu arriver
vers le 20 22 février des messages à
partir de l'iran et puis après l'italie
du nord mais jusqu'au 25 février
jusqu'au décès donc de monsieur varotto
à la pitié salpêtrière il n'y avait pas
sur le territoire français circulation
connues du virus donc on est dedans
c'était très étrange on se disait ça va
arriver quelque part
le virus est en train de se propager sur
la planète mais sur le territoire
français il n'y a pour l'instant dhr et
et je crois qu'il faut 20 il est très
difficile aujourd'hui de se remettre
dans l'état d'esprit où on était mais je
comprends très bien que pour des
personnes qui ne suivaient pas comme moi
l'épidémie il y avait pas de virus qui
circulait sur un territoire français
jusqu'au 25 février
moi évidemment j'étais inquiet en disant
ça nous arrivait de quelque part on sait
pas d'où mais pour l'instant et puis les
premiers cluster avait été bien
maîtrisée il faut aussi se souvenir
qu'on n'avait pas eu de cas secondaires
que des personnes étaient isolés que
donc on disait peut-être qu'en chine il
avait eu un problème très particulier
avec cette épidémie qui l'avait qui
était déjà très important de continuer à
découvert mais ailleurs
et c'était vrai pour l'ensemble des pays
touchés y compris la corée qui a réussi
à contrôler son premier cluster
l'épidémie semblait en tout cas
maîtrisable à cette époque 25 février
décès de monsieur varotto effectivement
la santé publique france puis la rs se
rendre compte que le virus circule est
dans l'oise et et c'est nous avec des
tests sérologiques qui rétrospectivement
avons pu reconstruire la circulation du
virus même époque où on ne savait pas
que le virus circule elle est ce qu il
faut savoir maintenant deuxième point
important c'est que c'est on est en
période hivernale les virus
respiratoires circulent on était en
période d'épidémie de grippe en février
donc les personnes qui toussait des
personnes qui avaient des la fièvre on
pensait d'abord à une grippe
ensuite d'autres virus respiratoires
possible dans les études qu'on a fait et
qui sont publiés et je vais regarder
juste un instant pour être sûr de ne pas
me tromper sur le mois de février dans
le lycée comme dans les écoles primaires
nous avions on avait classé no les
participants à l'étude comme ayant des
symptômes qu'on appelle majeur quand il
toussait qu'ils avaient de la fièvre des
troubles respiratoires dont des gens qui
avait quelque chose d'un peu cogner et
puis des symptômes mineurs quand c'était
juste un petit mal de gorge le nez qui
coule mais rien de plus il y avait plus
de personnes qui se plaignaient de
symptômes d'imageurs donc fièvre toux et
troubles respiratoires parmi des gens
qui n'ont pas été infectés par le grenat
virus que parmi les gens qui ont été
infectés par le virus donc même dans
cette période de levier
circule activement comme vous les 10
déjà autour de du lycée notamment en
février la majorité des personnes qui
avait fière tout et gêne respiratoire
avait autre chose que la coc vide il
avait vraisemblement une grippe il avait
vraisemblement un virus respiratoires
qui circulent donc faut vraiment et je
sais que cet exercice est difficile se
remettent dans cette ambiance de
jusqu'au 25 février le virus ne
circulait pas officiellement sur le
territoire français c'était l'épidémie
de grippe est d'ailleurs dans nos bases
de données même si on a pu documenter
rétrospectivement la circulation du
virus à crépy en valois
il y avait majoritairement des personnes
qui avaient d'autres virus respiratoires
quand il avait de la fièvre et de la
toux que des personnes qui avaient la
corrida ce moment là l'étude qu'on a
fait dans le lycée c'était aussi des
adolescents qui font des formes mineures
de la maladie donc on fait des choses
très très simple et quand j'ai pu sur le
webinar avec des participants ont pu
discuter un petit peu avec monsieur
bruno fortier et d'autres personnes
quand je leur ai dit le virus circule en
février ils m'ont tous regardé en me
disant mais on n'y a jamais pensé
enfin c'était vraiment pour eux un virus
respiratoires banal on était en épidémie
de grippe c'est l'hiver c'est normal ont
tous un peu on est et voilà donc je
voulais juste quand même nous remettre
en contexte parce que rétrospectivement
c'est très facile de dire mais comment
vous n'avez pas vu ce virus qui
circulait alors que la grande majorité
des gens avaient des symptômes
respiratoires tout à fait banale en
hiver et c'était d'ailleurs plus le cas
pour d'autres virus que pour l'aco vide
même si elle circulait dans ce lycée
assez activement merci une dernière
précision monsieur le directeur oui
juste pour répondre donc les conférences
audio ensuite vidéo enfin vision à
partir du 2 mars quasi quotidiennes avec
le national je précise juste une chose
sur les masques donc effectivement nous
avons eu conscience nous aussi et tous
collectivement des problèmes notamment
dans les ehpad et l'esad des cciad
nous avons donc début mars en fait avec
l'accord du de l'hôpital de beauvais
nous avons pris une palette de 32 mille
masques sur la fameuse dotation j'ai
acheté hospitalière pour alimenter les
établissements les services en dehors
pour pouvoir alimenter dans cette
période qui effectivement a été la plus
difficile
ensuite nous avions une enquête
permanente avec les établissements de
santé sur toute la région d'ailleurs et
on se débrouille toujours pour qu'ils
aient ou non au moins trois jours d'
avance et éventuellement s'il venait à
manquer nous organisions ou bien à
partir de nos stocks de dons ou bien en
dépannage interhospitalier nous faisions
est a priori dans l'oise je pense les
témoignages que j'ai eus récemment
encore je ne crois pas qu'ils aient
d'établissement qui a été en rupture
d'un établissement de santé de centrer
en rupture donc cesser sortez vous
parlez au nom de santé publique france
si je comprends bien non non non là je
jeu 200 toiles non mais mais c'est pour
ça c'est pour ça que je vous disais que
j'en avais fait cette dérogation j'avais
décidé cette dérogation sur l'oise les
trente-deux mille masques pour tenir
compte de cette situation compliquée
évidemment avec tous les apports très
important des collectivités
territoriales et du département en
particulier chez préfet le président
enfin pour compléter ce qui vient d'être
dit par eux et qui est le champion
directeur gérard leu rs on a procédé
conjointement d'ailleurs dans les
valeurs de duos des trios mais une
analyse vraiment très très fine
établissement par établissement pour
déterminer le nombre de jours
d'autonomie en équipements individuels
dont les masques donc ça c'est pas fait
de façon unilatérale uniforme
là on sentait qu avait des points de
tension et est donc on faisait en
complémentarité avec la rs et aussi avec
la présidente du conseil départemental
eh bien on apportait les équipements
individuels où les masses qui pouvait
manquer dans telle ou telle structure
alors dans l'oise on a la chance d'avoir
des entreprises industrielles puissante
qui nous ont aidés nous on était il ya
des équipementiers automobiles qui nous
ont aidés il ya aussi des sites
industriels dans le secteur du
cosmétique et de la betterave à ceux qui
nous ont aidés pour fournir le gel
hydroalcoolique en grande quantité bien
tout ça nous a permis de répondre à des
demandes ponctuelles de tel ou tel
établissement en complément c'est le
principe du bon sens la rs avait lui son
réseau j'allais dire hospitalier et
médico-social donc lui il remontait vers
lui tous les équipements et ensuite ils
retransféré comme il le disait a dit à
maintes reprises
loiselle des premiers départements
touchés ont pas remonter
équipement à lille pour les redescendre
dans l'oise donc ce qu'on l'a fait dans
les venu en appui et mais on a fait ça
pas comme ça au doigt mouillé
établissement par établissement il ya
soixante six ehpad dans département
bon et bien on le fait comme ça et on
est arrivé à faire face à pas toujours
dans les quantités souhaitées mais on a
toujours évité des situations de rupture
d'équipements individuels c'est comme ça
qu'on a procédé pour crépy en valois
merci à monsieur le maire de tout ce que
j'ai pu lire mais un rageux non mais
c'est la réalité
crépy en valois re était vraiment très
très touché très impactées à tous les
niveaux il fallait vraiment permettre au
maire de cette commune vous messieurs
portier de pouvoir rassurer la
population
on s'est débrouillé localement à préfet
connaît aussi son réseau d'entreprise il
sait aussi sur lesquels il peut
s'appuyer pour pourvoir aux demandes qui
ont exprimé pendant un nombre d'élus
donc c'est ce qu'on a fait
si nous permettait de ce président juste
un exemple
le badge monsieur le préfet a dit tout à
l'heure qu'il interdisait les marchés
moi j'ai voulu tant que j'ai pu le faire
redonner un morceau de vie à notre ville
et une semaine après cette interdiction
j'ai appelé monsieur le préfet en dix
ans le seul préfet moi je veux remettre
en route les marchés donc la préfecture
monsieur le préfet m'a donné une liste
de recommandations à suivre
entouré le marché faire une entrée et
une sortie un comptage distribuer à tous
les marchands un masque et des grands à
l'époque on de ont demandé des gants
ensuite les gants été retiré et il y
avait également un film devant tous les
étalages j'ai rouvert les marchés on en
a le dimanche et le mercredi une semaine
après en précisant toutes les
protections a réclamé par la brevets
turquie ont été suivis je distribuais
moi même tous les matins à 7 heures les
masques à tous les marchands qui devait
les mettre
je demandais la police municipale de
passer dans la matinée pour savoir si
les marchands portaient les masques
sinon ils étaient retirés du marché
et tout ça a fonctionné parfaitement
dans les règles avec un espacement d'un
mètre une file d'entrée tout ça a bien
fonctionné mais là aussi je donnais des
masques aux marchands parce qu'ils n'en
avaient pas voilà je reviens aussi à la
base pour les masques les marchands n'en
avait pas et donc je me faisais fort que
de leur donner des masques pour pouvoir
fonctionner voilà cet exemple merci
bernard jomier notre deuxième rapporteur
merci monsieur présent je voudrais faire
deux trois observations avant de poser
mes questions d'abord dire à monsieur le
maire son témoignage était très touchant
mais que qui ne se ne s'inquiète pas
pour l'image de crépy en valois
le sortira certainement pas altéré de
cette crise par contre bien au contraire
je ne sais pas parce que le fait que les
épidémies donne lieu à une
stigmatisation je crois que ça doit être
à peu près aussi vieux que le phénomène
épidémique dans le monde
mais ce n'est pas un lien qui
automatique pour autant et la qualité de
la réponse politique par les
responsables publics à une épidémie
modifie justement le rapport de la
population à ce qu'est une épidémie pour
être très clair quand vous gérez une
épidémie par la peur vous générez la
stigmatisation supplémentaire quand vous
gérez une épidémie par l'empowerment
pardon pour cet anglicisme les
populations par une politique de santé
publique ou la population s'approprie
devient acteur de sa santé et fait face
ensemble aux défis de l'épidémie eh ben
vous diminuez cette stigmatisation voilà
c'était une remarque préliminaire vous y
reviendrez monsieur le maire comme vous
en faites pas parce que je vous
interroger aussi je voudrais revenir
la deuxième remarque pardon je la fais
quasiment à chaque fois c'est que on
n'est pas là évidemment pour avoir un
jugement en quoi que ce soit sur ce qui
a été votre action mais pour comprendre
est ce que notre pays aurait pu réagir
plus rapidement et dans de meilleures
conditions
peut-être que non après tout peut-être
qu'on a tous fait au mieux et que nos
process sont bons peut-être qu'il ya des
marges de progression et c'est ce que
nous recherchons
et donc ne nous ne vous méprenez surtout
pas sur le sens des questions monsieur
le directeur de la rs vous êtes le
premier à nous faire part d'un
calendrier aussi précoce évidemment ma
collègue catherine de roche n'a pas
manqué de mettre le doigt dessus puisque
vous nous dites en gros dès mi-février
on a commencé à recevoir des alertes et
le 23 janvier pardon et mi janvier
nous avons commencé à préparer la crise
ce qui est donc près de deux mois avant
le confinement général de la population
décrétée par le gouvernement ces alertes
que vous avez reçu vous nous parlez de
messages un peu
ul qui sont transmis par la dgs sur des
phénomènes qui se passe dans le monde
entier
est-ce que mi-janvier à ce moment-là il
évoquait déjà un lien possible ou une
arrivée possible en france de ce
phénomène de ce coronavirus ou est-ce
que c'était une alerte on va dire
général comme vous en recevez des
dizaines et des dizaines et à partir de
ce moment là est ce que vous avez eu des
échanges réguliers avec les tutelles et
est ce que des mesures ont commencé à
être mises en place dont vous nous avez
dit des visioconférences mais là on est
plutôt début mars vous avez précisé donc
il ya encore une fois je le dis parce
que c'est ressorti lors d'auditions
précédente
un espèce de trou noir sur le mois de
février et j'y reviendrai donc on
aimerait comprendre ce qui s'est passé
pendant ce mois de février outre la
situation locale qui a été la vôtre
monsieur le préfet vous nous avez
expliquer comment vous avez travaillez
vous avez plusieurs expressions très
très forte vous avez dit bah on a pris
notre sort en main vous avez parlé de
l'absence de mesures nationales
vous avez dit après on s'est débrouillé
localement donc vous avez fait face
ensemble on va dire au mieux en vous
articulant les uns avec les autres
vous êtes préfet vous êtes selon le code
de santé publique chargée de coordonner
et de pilotage de la réponse à une
épidémie avec toute crise d'ailleurs à
la gestion de crise vous êtes préfet
donc la gestion de crise vous connaissez
ça avez vous été un moment confrontés à
la gestion d'une épidémie auparavant
et il y avez vous été la question
pourrait s'adresser à tous les préfets
un pas particulièrement à vous former à
la gestion de ce qu'est une crise
épidémique est quand même un phénomène
bien particulier madame la présidente
moi j'aurais voulu vous interroger sur
et comme madame la directrice
plus spécifiquement sur les actions vous
avez mis en place en direction des ehpad
quand avez vous compris ou senti qu'il y
avait un problème spécifique avec les
espaces parce qu'au niveau national
c'était très lent tout de même
et quelles actions avez-vous mis ou
tenter
de mettre en place vis-à-vis des ehpad
et moi j'aimerais plus vous alliez plus
loin sur cette question de la double
tutelle qu'on n'en reste pas l'habituel
constat qui fait consensus mais c'est
quoi votre proposition à la matière est
ce que il faut enlever la tutelle
sanitaires sur les ai pas ce qui serait
quand même un peu étonnant à l'issue de
cette crise est ce qu'il faut c'est que
c'est c'est quoi ce serait quoi votre
piste de de réflexion pour que justement
on soit plus opérationnelle à l'avenir
sur les étals monsieur le maire vous
nous avez dit vous a parlé du 25 février
vous nous avez dit j'ai demandé à mon de
gs de vérifier le stock de masques et
m'a dit qu'il en est
il y en a plus aucun on n'a plus rien le
lendemain matin était assis à quelques
mètres là bas non seulement monsieur
fontanes et d'ailleurs je m'en rappelle
mais le directeur général de la santé
monsieur salomon et qui nous a dit la
pénurie de masse n'est pas un sujet
alors c'est pas contradictoire avec
votre constat mais par contre la réponse
que vous allez faire à la question
pourrait générer de la contradiction
constatant que vous n'avez pas de masque
vous avez certainement chercher en
obtenir avez vous pu obtenir rapidement
des masques pour reconstituer votre
stock et et les utiliser et enfin
monsieur fontanes et alors la question
dépasse et évidemment l'oise mais encore
une fois il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses en janvier il semblerait que mi
janvier les chinois et publié transmis
alors à leurs collègues à la communauté
scientifique la carte d'identité du
virus et que les allemands et à ce
moment là mis en route la fabrication de
tests
que s'est il passé en france
j'imagine que mi-janvier aussi la carte
d'identité a été gardé dans l'étude a
été reçue que s'est il passé à ce moment
là et selon quel calendrier sur cette
question des tests
voilà je remercie bien questions très
précises monsieur le rapporteur réponse
précise la première s'adresse à monsieur
le directeur de la rs oui
alors je notamment dans les auditions de
de madame la ministre de la santé à
l'époque elle a donné sa tendance et l
assemblée où les a pas encore set mais
elle a donné un centre de toute façon la
liste des mines santé qui ont été
transmis je pense évidemment par
construction vous les voulez vous voulez
demander
on a donc eu régulièrement et donc dès
la fin janvier des informations qui
effectivement au départ sont d
informations internationales mais
internationale veut pas dire qu'on ne
s'y intéressent pas je voudrais juste
donner un exemple parce que en fait même
moi je vais vous dire franchement là
évidemment avec cette audition je me
suis un peu replonger dans un passé qui
a la foi est très récent mais qui vu
tout ce qui s'est passé honnêtement
paraît déjà assez loin tant il ya un
point qu'on a oublié et c'est d'ailleurs
ça donne écho à ce que disait le
professeur fontanet tout à l'heure avant
cette cette nuit dramatique quand même
du 25 au 26 février où on commence par
un décès nous avons passé le mois de
février a à faire du contact racing
paradoxalement c'est à dire que nous
avons eu 42 cas possibles investiguer
des gens qui étaient suffisantes suspect
qu'on a mis compris parce qu'au départ
on est dans des mesures de précautions
extrêmes y compris vous savez dans des
chambres à pression positive fait ça
avec un système très très lourd de prise
en charge parce que c'est la doctrine
évidemment quand on a un virus émergents
on ne prend aucun risque
mais tout ça pour vous dire qu'en fait
le mois de février paradoxalement alors
même qu' on a l'impression effectivement
qu il ne se passe pas grand chose et
même bouger quand j'y repense et après
je me suis bien non en fait la rs mais
jeudi la grèce c'était vrai dans toute
la france en la rs en fait et son et les
équipes de santé publique france en fait
on est déjà dans l'épidémie il s'avère
qu'en fait elle n'est pas là puisqu'à
chaque fois un les quarante deux fois
nous avons un cas possible
d'abord vous savez cas suspects cas
possible identifier un par par les
régulations prise en charge test
et puis à l'époque les tests voilà on a
il faut que ce soit fait à paris parce
qu'on est vraiment au tout début et donc
on est déjà dans la crise donc on a des
relations avec le national très
régulière
on échange sur ces éléments là il ya le
centre de crise sanitaire qui s'est
activé et qui on remonte toutes ces
données tous ces cas possibles sont tout
ça commence déjà
et donc en fait effectivement comme le
dit très bien le professeur phung années
avant le 26 février
nous n'avons absolument pas conscience
virus circule dans l'oise personne ne le
sait tout le monde pense évidemment
qu'éventuellement ce qu'on pense avant
le 26 et qu'on va être dans une
situation c'est ça qu'on compense avoir
c'est la situation des contamines c'est
à dire tomber sur un cas qu'on va avoir
récupéré justement dans le cadre de
cette procédure cas suspects cas
possible parce que il vient où il a été
en contact avec un gain de 2,2 chine et
c est en fait ce qu'on a dans l'oise
mais on ne le sait qu'à poster des
situations totalement différente mais ça
ne veut pas dire que pendant tout ce
mois
on n'a pas une activation très forte de
la veille et de la sécurité sanitaire
parce que ça nous occupe au quotidien
donc on est déjà si vous voulez dans la
crise on n'est pas même si en fait à
chaque fois le malade n'en est pas un il
y en a eu 1 ailleurs mais des cas
importés mais pas chez nous sur et donc
ses relations avec le national health
ont elles sont déjà extrêmement active
que ce soit donc de manière assez
formaliser les mines sentent les
remontées d'informations de notre côté
ou même des échanges que moi je peux
avoir directement
c'est déjà assez actif après
effectivement les choses se formalise
plus et de manière vous dit quasi
quotidiennes avec à partir du début mars
et audio tous les soirs il est déjà des
échanges vont être les briller bien sûr
monsieur très concis comme réponse parce
qu'il ya de nombreuses questions qui
sont encore à poser très bien sûr à
porter alors pour répondre
derrière à deux points sur votre
question concernant le préfet de
département de façon générale pour tout
d'abord dans le pur l'oise quand je vous
ai dit absence de mesures nationales ce
qui est l'absence d'arrêté décret au
tout début de la crise mais pas absence
de parole gouvernemental voilà
le ministre de la santé s'est rendu à
crépy en valois le vendredi 28 février
et annoncé que dès le 1er mars
certains établissements scolaires du
département seront fermées sur décision
conjointe du préfet et de la rectrice
d'académie
premier élément deuxième élément samedi
20 février
il annonce que dans les communes cluster
neuf dans l'oise tous les rassemblements
vont être interdits des établissements
scolaires des communes cluster qui
compte des cas contacts qui présente
donc un risque plus élevé ne rouvriront
pas le lundi 2 mars
vous voyez fort de ces éléments moi j'ai
pris les arrêtés préfectoraux
correspondant prend les points ensuite
sur l'aspect est ce qu'un préfet formés
à la gestion d'une épidémie et pour ce
qui me concerne c'est ce que j'ai été
amené à ce type de situation de gestion
de crise une fois dans ma vie j'ai été
amené à gérer je n'étais pas prêt fait
en nouvelle calédonie gestion d'une
épidémie stella dingue
voilà bon alors je veux dire c'est pas
le grenat virus m'enfin ça donne un
avant goût de ce qui peut peut se
produire il n'y a pas eu évidemment août
aux morts ce que je tiens surtout à vous
dire et jean conclurait mon pauvre par
là un préfet n'est pas seul un préfet
c'est vrai et d'une autorité général
administratif coordinatrice il a surtout
à ses côtés la chance d'avoir un
directeur général dont loison clé car on
était le seul département touchées dont
qu'il m'avait complètement pour moi la
pluie du directeur général de la rs
quand compétence directe à sur les
questions sanitaires
c'est lui qui a les compétences et donc
je m'entoure de ceux qui sont qui sont
en capacité de gérer une crise du
patient moi mon rôle c'est surtout de
faire en sorte que la crise soit
pleinement comprise et que les mesures
qui doivent être prises soient
pleinement accepté par les élus
merci
madame la présidente vous propositions
sur le double tutelle avait une autre
question auparavant sur les actions
mises en place
donc les actions mises en mise en place
moi j'ai tenu dès le début c'est à dire
des dès les premiers jours du mois du
mois de mars puisque c'est que mes
services appelle tous les jours les
ehpad et ensuite on a mis un tableau en
place de façon à faire remonter tous les
problèmes voilà ça c'était la première
la première la première chose
ensuite on s'est vite rendu compte mais
ça il ya eu un échange avec la rs qu'il
fallait interdire les visites puisqu'on
savait très bien que lorsque le le virus
entrait dans un ehpad
malheureusement il faisait beaucoup de
dégâts mais qui dit interdiction de
visite dit aussi grande difficulté pour
les personnes âgées qui finalement n'ont
plus de visites ne voient plus leurs
familles et voilà donc nous nous avons
nous avons acheté nous avons proposé à
tous les ehpad des tablettes connectées
de façon à ce qu'ils puissent avoir un
contact avec leur famille voire leurs
petits-enfants même si c'est par
tablette interposés mais malgré tout
qu'il puisse y avoir un contact
et puis concernant les masques dans les
masses que nous avons acheté nous avons
toujours veillé c'est pour ça que tout à
l'heure il a été dit qui ne manquait pas
de masque dans les ehpad
c'est qu'entre deux livraisons via la de
la rs nous nous en avions pour faire le
trait d'union si vous voulez entre deux
livraisons si un ehpad disais bon moi je
suis vraiment en fin de stock jeu j'ai
peur de pas faire face en attendant la
livraison de données pas de la rs à ce
moment là nous nous j'avais un service
qu'ils allaient porter des masques
directement dans les ehpad où ces
préfets disais tout à l'heure 67 et
ehpad dans l'oise tout confondu un
public et privé et donc nous avons
assumé la même la même chose que ce soit
pour les publics et les et les privés et
puis j'ai eu
1 j'ai eu comment un contact avec des
médecins qui m'ont qui m'ont appelé dix
ans mais il ya un souci quand même dans
les ehpad sur le plan médical
ck nepad qui est rattachée à un hôpital
un médecin permanent ou des médecins les
autres c'est déjà plus compliqué puisque
selon ce sont des médecins traitants qui
font des vacations et qui vont voir
leurs patients à l'hôpital donc là
c'était plus compliqué et là j'ai eu un
certain nombre de médecins locaux qui
m'ont dit mais si on pouvait avoir 17 au
scope électronique de façon à pouvoir de
notre cabinet aussi avoir les
informations
donc on a regardé ça de près nous avons
interrogés chaque ehpad et nous avons
acheté les stéthoscopes électronique
pour tous les ehpad qui on demandait
voilà donc ces voilà ce que nous ce que
nous avons fait et ensuite lorsqu'il ya
eu plus de masques puisqu'il ya période
difficile après une période où ça s'est
amélioré
eh bien nous n'avons plus alimenter les
ehpad puisque la rs le faisait mais par
contre nous avons alimenté en masquer
les ehpad
une fois que les visites étaient à
nouveau autorisés de façon à ce que les
familles et un masque lire s'il venait
sans masque eh bien on donnait un masque
de façon à ce que les ehpad ne donne pas
les masques qui était prévu pour le
personnel hospitalier ou pour les peaux
les résidents donc voila un petit peu ce
qui a été fait pour les ehpad après je
vais pas développer puisque si vous
m'avez pas posé la question mais il y a
les personnes âgées dans les ehpad
mais il y à toutes les personnes âgées à
domicile sont de plus en plus nombreux
aussi et là aussi il fallait aussi faire
des choses concernant la co la cotutelle
vous dire un peu ce que ressentent les
départements finance voilà et après il
n'y a pas je trouve le lien qui devrait
y avoir et on peut rester en cotutelle
j'en sais rien c'est pas moi d'analyser
ça mais en tout cas il faut un travail
beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus en commun je dirais avec
avec la rs parce qu'il faut qu'il ya des
décisions je pense qu'il serait
intéressant qu'on l'ait qu'on les
prennent ensemble je vous donne un
exemple la grèce même s'il ya une
délégation locale la rl les ai pas nous
les avons quasiment tous les jours au
téléphone il ya toujours une question
sur un prix de journée sur quelque chose
et c est moi je pense que on a quand
même un nombre d'informations important
qu'on pourrait partager mieux avec les
la rs et la rs même si son rayonnement
son sa mission première c'est la santé
et bien dans les ehpad on peut pas faire
du copier coller partout il ya des
spécificités locales ou deux dans
certains centres et ceux qui sont
rattachés aux hôpitaux sont ou ne sont
pas rattachés aux hôpitaux etc
et je pense que là il ya un manque et
cette crise a démontré que ce manque
était vraiment flagrant voilà parce que
je et moi je ne sais pas c'est pas moi
qui vais proposer je suis pas juge pas
parlementaire mais ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'il faut impérativement revoir
cette co tutelle
ils mettent des liens différents des
passerelles différentes entre nous et
qu'il y est meilleure qu une
collaboration que ce soit moins
technocratique mais beaucoup plus liées
au terrain voilà merci monsieur le maire
sur le web et vous huent vos masques
rapidement et si vous voulez dès qu'on
s'est aperçu qu'on avait pas de masque
on a essayé d'en chercher on en a trouvé
20000 on en a acheté tout de suite 20
milles pourquoi parce que là on parle de
la population on parle des médecins etc
des ehpad
mais moi j'ai 269 salariés qu'il fallait
protéger avec au moins deux masques par
jour et il n'était pas question que le
personnel municipal manque également de
deux masques on a également un ccas où
il ya environ 80 personnes
donc là aussi il fallait absolument
avoir des masques le problème si vous
voulez c'est c'est qu'ensuite il ya eu
un flou terrible et les communes se sont
retrouvés tout seul même si on était
aidé par département le préfet et cetera
ou comment deux tons des masques qui
officiellement peut en vendre elle ce
qu'ils sont corrects est-ce qu'ils sont
adaptés enfin voilà donc on a cherché
sur internet comme tout le monde le
faisait mais c'était un vaste chantier
excusez moi on avait des gens de
belgique qui nous appelaient en avait
des gens d'espagne qui nous envoyait des
mails etc
et là il ya eu un flou il ya eu un flot
pour acheter derrière des masques plus
que nous on en a acheté en tout plus de
50 milles et on a fait des distributions
à la population y compris d'ailleurs la
région par l'intermédiaire de son
président xavier bertrand qui avait donc
proposé de faire un masque par personne
mais mais franchement au sujet des
masques quand on a voulu en acheter en
particulier les
les masque en tissu réutilisables on ne
savait pas du tout où aller pour pour
avoir ces basses donc on s'est
débrouillé et on en a acheté pour 97 me
voilà cent mille euros de masse qu'on a
qu'on a redistribué mais oui
effectivement au départ on a récupéré 20
mille masques jetables que je voulais
pour le personnel de la commune
alors merci j'ai la parole je continue
monsieur le président simplement
simplement oui je simplement ce qu'il
faudrait mettre au plan local comme au
plan départemental
on a dans toutes les communes un plan
communal de sauvegarde
ce plan communal de sauvegarde donne un
certain nombre il ya une obligation pour
le maire etc
et il ya une classification qu'on
appelle la classification des risques
majeurs
il ya les inondations l'inondation
brutale feux de forêts etc
je vais pas tout vous les citer la
pandémie n'existe pas la pandémie
n'existe pas donc que fait-on acquis
téléphone taux qui est autorisé à nous
vendre ceux ci qui est autorisé à nous
donner cela etc
nous nous étions voilà ce plan communal
de sauvegarde avec la casse pandémie me
manque terriblement comme allemands qu'à
l'ensemble des mains sales usa et elle
devrait être remis je suppose qu'il ya
un plan de sauvegarde au niveau du
département
voilà donc ça c'est important c'est le
terrain et c'est la base de ce que nous
vivons pour simplement revenir sur
l'aller les crépynois qui était
stigmatisée croyez moi tous les
crépynois on
disait qu'on était des pestiférés
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui encore
venait à crépy je vous invite venez nous
voir on est le seul musée de l'archerie
en europe
je vous le présenterai et on va discuter
avec les crétinoir et on verrait dans
quel état d'esprit les crépynois ont
encore cette notion de pestiférés qui
reste en merci seule mère je ne dis plus
rien monsieur fontani vous aviez une
question sur la thèse la rapidité de
fiabilité des tests par rapport à
l'allemagne
voilà donc le déploiement des tests en
fait
suse alors il ya des éléments que je
pourrais pas ok je préparais pompe qui
concerne ensemble la france je vous hais
les éléments dont je suis au courant
comme vous le rappeliez le 10 janvier
la séquence complète du nouveau corps
navires us et mises en ligne par des
scientifiques chinois le 17 janvier
christian gross tonnes virologue à
charité berlin on voit des premiers à
mort ces kits qui permettent de faire
des réactions d'identification de ce
virus donc ces fameux tests
rt pcr avec le prélèvement nasopharyngé
en parallèle l'institut pasteur
développer son propre test puisque honda
le centre national de référence des
virus respiratoires avec ses livres
d'art vers cette capacité
le 23 janvier nous partageons avec le
ses nerfs des laboratoires des virus
respiratoires de lyon chez bruno lina
les kits amorce qui ont été fournies par
christian gross tonnes mais également ce
qu'on appelle un témoin positif et qui a
été donc fabriqué un institut pasteur la
difficulté c'est que quand vous faites
tourner votre réaction si vous avez un
résultat négatif
vous avez besoin d'avoir un témoin qui
lui est positif pour vous dire que s'il
est positif votre action a bien marché
et donc le fait que vous êtes un
résultat négatif n'est pas parce que
votre test ne marche pas puisque votre
témoin positif s'allumer or c'est
difficile de faire ces témoins positif
donc le fait partie delà de ce qui
devait accompagner les kits et amorce
que christian gross tonnes avait envoyé
ses ce témoin qui s'allument qui vous
dit votre réaction marche bien si votre
résultat avait été positif
eh ben vous le verriez puisque votre
témoin positif c'est à lui mais je sais
pas si je suis clair mais mais bon ça
fait partie techniquement des choses qui
sont nécessaires pour s'assurer que
votre tête et la question était qui est
ce que on a eu un retard sur la
validation des ten certification des
tests par rapport à l'allemagne non
alors là je vous donne tout est
chronologique est importante parce que
c'est tout un travail de développer ces
tests en urgence il y a quand je vous
disais on est partis du 10 janvier le 17
on reçoit les kits de berlin le 23 et 24
on avait notre propre test opérationnel
à l'institut pasteur
on les partage avec le cnr de lyon on
partage également avec lyon l'équipe qui
avait été envoyé par christian gross
tonnes on leur fournit le témoin positif
pour qu'ils soient sûrs d'avoir une
réaction qui fonctionne le 29 janvier
ont fait la séquençage complet du génome
à partir des cas qui est arrivé en
france le 24 janvier à l'institut
pasteur de 7 février
on transmet aux établissements santé de
référence
le kit de diagnostic le protocole
d'utilisation les fameux témoin positif
pour leur permettre d'être en mesure de
réaliser ces tests et le 14 février on
transmet aux hôpitaux dits de deuxième
ligne
l'ensemble de ces éléments qui tu
amorces pcr et c'est donc bon ça c'est
le travail du centre national de
référence 1 d'être en capacité de
développer un test on avait celui des
allemands mais on a développé le nôtre
qui d'ailleurs aux dires de bruno lina
était plus performant que le
qu'idéalement bon ça c'est pas très
d'accord
dans le fait de tester très bon test ils
ont été distribués quand l'équipe
président était moins positifs ont été
disponibles après la difficulté qui se
pose c'est le passage à l'échelle et
c'est là que revient votre question et
que je pensais et la leçon qu'il faudra
qu'on apprenne pour la prochaine crise
c'est que vous avez des labos des cnrd
sensation de référence qui sont en
mesure de développer des tests innovant
aussi bien en allemagne qu'en france
dans des délais qui vont prendre 15
jours à peu près là on a un test qui
marchent merula dans un labo comment est
ce que vous faites le passage à
l'échelle pour que ce test soit
disponible d'abord dans des
établissements de référence puis après
dans des hôpitaux dit de deuxième ligne
c'est ce passage à l'échelle qui je
pense devra être repensé la difficulté
que nous on a rencontré c'est que bon on
avait fait notre job de développer le
test on le distribue en quantités
limitées parce qu'on n'a pas des
capacités industrielles c'est pas notre
boulot de développer des tests en
capacité industrielle pour alimenter des
labos de france il faut donc que ces
labos puisse avoir des réactifs keys et
les amorces on leur donne tout les codes
génétiques qui sont nécessaires pour les
faire donc ils font leurs commandes et
c'est là que sont arrivés des pénuries
de dames anse de réactifs des lots qui
ont été contaminées qui ont été envoyés
sur plusieurs hôpitaux français là je
parle des fournisseurs et la difficulté
aussi c'est que beaucoup des
laboratoires français fonctionne avec
des des équipements qui sont des
équipements qu'on appelle fermé c'est à
dire qu'ils sont dépendants de la
compagnie qui leur a fourni qui ne
peuvent être utilisés qu'avec des
réactifs de cette compagnie or quand
vous êtes dans une situation comme celle
ci où vous devez développer un nouveau
test il vous faut en fait des
équipements dits ouverts qu'ils sont
capables d'accueillir ces tests qu'on
appelle maisons qui ont été faits comme
kiss de christian gross tonnes ou le kit
de civils vous entendez revers et que
l'on doit pouvoir déployer rapidement et
je pense que la réflexion que vous
devrez avoir elle sera à sur une
prochaine pandémie
comment les labos français ou au moins
un réseau de laboratoires référence
français puis cette équipe tu es avec
des équipements dits ouverts qui leur
permettraient très rapidement de
s'adapter à une nouvelle technologie
et ne pas être dépendant des équipements
fermé qu'ils ont acheté clé en main qui
sont beaucoup plus faciles d'utilisation
mais qui sont dépendants des kits que
leur fournit la compagnie et qu'ils ne
peuvent rien faire d'autre donc dire
aujourd'hui monsieur le professeur
qu'ils sont toujours fermés cc lauriane
tout il ya des laboratoires de chu qui
ont des kits qui ont des équipements
ouvert ils sont capables de s'adapter
puis en a d'autres qui ne passe pas et
je crois que l'adresse div
alors vous voulez mais pas réglé cette
question quand même je pense qu'il sera
important que vous la pause iea des à
des personnes comme sylvie van der werf
ou bruno lina qui sont responsables des
centres nationaux de référence parce que
c'est vraiment eux qui ont le savoir
c'est vraiment eux qui ont le savoir sur
ces questions il reviendrait pas vous
induire en erreur
mais la compréhension que j'en ai de
tout ce que vous avez pu voir c'est que
autant au niveau entre guillemets de
développement du test etc
je pense qu'on a été plutôt performants
on a eu des tests rapidement et fiable
je rappelle que ces 17 h en terrasse qui
a développé un test qui n'étaient pas
fiables c'est comme les uns des labos de
référence du monde un truisme donc on a
fait le boulot
la partie difficile c'est le moment vous
pouvez passer à l'échelle et l'envoyer
dans des hôpitaux de référence d'abord
puis de deuxième lit ou là vous devez
avoir des équipements compatibles avec
réactif amorce tests etc
et c'est là on s'est retrouvé dans tout
les problèmes de pénurie puisque le
monde entier ont pendant la première
quinzaine de mars a voulu avoir les
mêmes réactifs les mêmes amorce des
mêmes et c'est donc là il ya eu une ça
donc garder en mémoire que ces questions
il est important que vous les reposiez
aux personnes qui ont le vrai savoir
qu'ils sont au moins sept vivent des
revers bruno lina parce qu'ils sont des
directeurs des centres nationaux de
référence mais je voulais au moins vous
apporter ces éléments d'informations
pour vous éclairer dans votre première
investigations merci avant de vous
passer la parole madame la directrice
vous permettez on va prendre les
questions de nos collègues pour faire
des des réponses un peu globalisé un
avance puisque nous collègues sont
impatients de vous poser un certain
nombre de questions et on peut les
comprendre alors il ya olivier paccaud
qui nous a demandé déjà la parole le
local de l'étape
tout à fait merci monsieur le président
et cher
chers amis de l'oise effectivement vaud
a payé un très lourd tribut à la
pandémie
beaucoup de choses ont été dites pour
faire face il ya eu extrêmement fins
beaucoup de bonne volonté mais il ya eu
aussi et surtout ce que je dirai ce que
j'appellerais un système d où un système
s de solidarité beaucoup de choses ont
été dites moi je rajouterais quand même
cette espèce de d'extraordinaire vague
de solidarité qu'on a vu dans les
communes avec des commandos de
couturière avec des as de la 3d qui ont
fait des visières avec des élus locaux
qui ont fait un travail tout à fait
extraordinaire avec des parlementaires
et je vais en citer deux qui ont fourni
un nombre de pays tout à fait incroyable
s'agisse de carole dureau bonnart ou
d'olivier dassault qui ont fourni
beaucoup de masques ils sont même allés
jusqu'à fournir dans le cas d'heuliez
d'assaut des housses mortuaires des
housses mortuaires à la demande du
sous-préfet de clairement donc il ya eu
des choses formidables pour faire face
mais a eu des loupés il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements doux mais nous mes
questions je reviendrai pas sur la base
aérienne de creil me faudra y revenir
il faudra y revenir parce que les 193
rapatriés de one se sont posés à istres
ils ont été mis en 14 n les militaires
qui les ont ramenés et qui était basé à
creil n'ont pas été mis en 14 n ensuite
ou bien que monsieur fontanet dit que
rien ne se soit passé on ne peut pas ne
pas voir un scepticisme forcené
concernant un départ d'épidémie à ce
niveau là je rappelle que monsieur
gossard le deuxième malades étaient
personnels civils de la base je rappelle
que le nombre
de malades confirmés au tout début de
l'épidémie partie de la base et non est
important j'ai des questions maintenant
très précise d'abord au sujet monsieur
le directeur de la rs je veux revenir
sur un quelque chose vous avez peu
évoquée c'est le rôle des professionnels
de santé notamment les médecins
généralistes les infirmières diplômées
parce que la plupart regrettent se
plaignent de ne pas ou ne peut avoir été
associés à la gestion de la crise
d'avoir été peu informés il s'est quand
même une armée de 550 toubib dans l'oise
700 infirmières et ils sont convaincus
j'ai pas mal de témoignages ils sont
convaincus que il aurait pu être
beaucoup mieux insérées dans le
dispositif vous avez un peu parlé de
télémédecine je pense que il ya eu un
manque à ce niveau là et j'aimerais
avoir votre votre vision
ensuite je veux revenir un tout petit
peu sur les masques et il ya eu des
choses dites par monsieur daumier madame
de roche 23 janvier vous avez votre
première réunion de crise des
instructions et vous commencez à parler
de masques vous vous me dites y'a à
partir du 18 mars une grosse livraison
nous ne sommes pas en charge des masques
c'est au niveau national toujours est il
que vous avez senti monter la pandémie
vous avez senti
vous avez entendu des demandes même si
on l'a vu à crépy y avait dans la
plupart des établissements des hôpitaux
il y avait des stocks mais les autres
professionnels de santé
alors ça peut être les dentistes les
infirmières les soins à domicile
il ya eu 1 1 un manque criant et moi je
voudrais savoir à partir de quand vous à
la rs des hôtes france faut quand même
savoir que dans l'oise la directrice de
la rs a été nommée la directrice
départementale le 16 mars
le poste était vacant depuis quasiment
un an
il y avait une faisant office mais une
faisons office l'appelle madame pionchon
qui a travaillé au département on la
connaît bien
mais la directrice madame d'années a été
nommé le 16 mars
donc vous monsieur champions à partir de
quand avez-vous pris conscience du fait
qu'il fallait vraiment faire venir des
masques
je vous dis ça parce que hier nous avons
eu votre homologue de mayotte
madame voynet qui nous a dit qu'elle
avait la grande fierté d'avoir pu
fournir le 17 mars à tous les acteurs de
la chaîne de santé quand je dis tous les
acteurs elle a précisé elle même que ça
allait jusqu'à l'ambulancier le 17 mars
tous les acteurs de la chaîne de santé
étaient en possession alors au moins de
deux masques par jour pour les
ambulanciers c'est son témoignage hier
en ce qui concerne les stocks qui
pouvait y avoir dans les hôpitaux ou
pour tous les professionnels de santé y
at il de la part de la rs des
vérifications qui sont effectués
monsieur le préfet alors vous êtes un
ancien militaire et on a tous admirer et
apprécier votre capacité à faire face
président la république avait dit que
c'était une guerre tout cas vous avez
tenu le front je peux en témoigner
on a compris que la bicéphale i c'est
pas un gage d'efficacité on a parlé du
haut etc
mais bon là bicéphale issa marche
rarement moi j'ai deux questions à vous
poser monsieur le préfet concernant deux
services publics
les forces de l'ordre et les enseignants
les forces de l'ordre au début de la
crise et je vous avais posé la question
souvenez vous un vendredi de réunion on
les voyait sans masque et il y a eu un
cas dans mon canton la gendarmerie de
huy huit gendarmes mis sur le flanc
y at-il eu des consignes mans prêtons de
moyens en ce qui concerne le port de
masques pour les forces de l'ordre
ensuite en ce qui concerne les
enseignants
ceux ci étaient
non pas réquisitionné mais tous ceux qui
étaient volontaires pour accueillir les
enfants de soignants et autres
donc venez dans les écoles mais on ne
leur fournit sait pas forcément on ne
leur fournit c'est pas forcément de
masques ou de matériel et donc il
pouvait refuser de venir
c'était du volontariat pur y at il eu à
ce niveau là des demandes de
l'inspectrice d'académie de la rectrice
pour être livrés être fournie en
matériel de protection
madame la présidente une seule question
très précise
vous avez parlé des ehpad il ya aussi
beaucoup d'aînés isolé et on a constaté
que la plupart des victimes
malheureusement était très âgé mais oui
j'ai plus que cette question et puis une
autre à bruno fortier et quelles actions
une une ce2
quelles actions le département peut
mener ou à mener envers les aînés isolés
et non pas dans les ehpad
enfin monsieur le maire de crépy bruno
on a constaté parmi les personnes peu
âgée touchée
beaucoup d'élus beaucoup d'élus
visiblement il y a eu le jour des
élections que ce soit en tenue de
bureaux de vote que ce soit au moment du
dépouillement
beaucoup de contamination j'ai une
pensée pour jean jacques vallet maire
adjoint de tracy qui est décédé il ya eu
beaucoup de notre collègue du
département eric de valroger a été mis
sur le flanc pendant un bon moment
bruno penses tu qu'il aurait fallu
reporter les élections municipales du 15
mars ont bercy je vous demanderais
d'être très précis dans vos questions le
local de l'est de l'oise temps bien sûr
martin lévriers merci monsieur le
président merci à toutes et à tous de
vous
témoignages qui sont passionnants et
très émouvant parfois aussi je vais
aller très vite parce que mes questions
étaient à peu près posé je reviens sur
les tests vous disiez monsieur le
professeur que vous étiez en pointe au
moment du lancement des tests à crépy et
au tour que la situation était emploi
tous connus sentiment à ce moment là que
le test les tests étaient à des moyen le
plus efficace pour juguler ou ralentir à
tout le moins cette pandémie
et si oui où je pouvais remonter la
formation et comment puisque on voit
qu'après effectivement dans l'appareil
tout à l'heure et c'est pas votre rôle
de nous l'expliquer mais on voit bien qu
après l'allemagne prend un chemin que
nous ne prenons pas vous dit que on est
en manque de réactifs
le monde entier est en route mais
l'allemagne elle réussit donc quelque
part est ce qu'on a été en a pris du
retard alors qu'on était en pointe ou
pas une question alors qui va vous
montrer mon inculture total le médical
ou vous parlez des virus en disant mais
on s'était l'hiver la plupart des gens
en fait avait la grippe est ce qu'on
peut avoir la grippe et le co vide en
même temps finalement est ce qu'il n'ya
pas un lien ça je non mais voilà la
cachant l'autre aux femmes en voilà
c'était un peu le voilà et puis et puis
question qui est qui qui est heureux
joint aussi un peu c'est est ce que
finalement il aurait été plus efficace
de confiner plutôt vous avez fait des
tentatives de confinement sur le marché
vous en parler le talent monsieur le
préfet est-ce qu'il fallait pas confiné
plus tôt et est ce qu'on n'avait pas dû
confiner plutôt dans toute la france
et effectivement le rôle non pas du jour
du vote parce que je suis très dubitatif
au jour du vote mais de la campagne
électorale qui était un lieu de
rassemblement permanent on ne la
donnerai tout se passe pour nous
beaucoup et est repassé franchement est
ce qu'il est ce qu'il fallait pas
confiné plus tôt et comment merci
beaucoup merci damien regnard
même si le président je m'attendais pas
si rapidement moi j'ai vraiment 2 2 deux
remarques
la première pour paraphraser kissinger
quand j'appelle l'europe quel numéro et
là je vous demande la même question quel
numéro
moi j'ai essayé le 7 et 8 février
d'appeler ministère de la santé 0 au
retour 0 personnes la seule personne que
j'ai pu avoir à travers mes différents
contacts c'est le directeur du centre de
crise et la directrice à la directrice
adjointe de la f1 car depuis le mois de
janvier
en tant que sénateur des français
établis hors de france on voyait la
panique pas seulement en chine mais
également au vietnam et dans toute la
zone
donc quel numéro quelle était votre
interlocuteur me servais santé qui sert
l'intérieur dans notre magnifique
millefeuille administratif et
territorial
on finit par s'y perdre en tout cas pour
moi et j'aimerais savoir puisque on a la
chance d'avoir un préfet ancien
militaire une chaîne de commandement et
à ministère de l'intérieur mobilisé la
deuxième le deuxième commentaire très
rapide c'est que ça colle pas je suis
désolé mais ça ne colle pas les dates le
calendrier que vous nous donner ne colle
pas le 23 janvier air france société de
référence au niveau international dans
le domaine de la sécurité
pour de nombreuses multinationales
supprime ses vols sur au départ de juan
on envoie nous un aveu un avion
militaire le 31 janvier
la chine continue air china continue ses
vols quotidiens avec une autre compagnie
je croise artistes china quotidien je
deviens quotidien sur la france
pendant tout le mois de février une
grande partie du mois de mars vous nous
dites que le 25 février on avait
l'impression si j'ai bien entendu et
compris le virus ne circulaient plus ou
pas on peut en france on était à ce
moment là si mes souvenirs sont bons en
plaine en plein début de crise en italie
à nos portes à nos frontières
enfin je pourrais comme ça à revenir sur
un certain nombre de dates et dire mais
vous vous êtes inquiétés monsieur le
maire et j'ai entendu parler de mi
janvier mi janvier oui nous nous
français établis hors de france avec nos
contacts et nos élus locaux dans les
différents pays on était déjà un petit
peu inquiet est ce qu on pourrait avoir
une chronologie une chronologie logique
parce que là ça tient pas je suis désolé
mais là il n'y a aucun vous êtes en
contradiction le 30 et le jeu nous avait
dit monsieur le maire et ses tresses est
tout à fait à votre honneur que le 25
février
des inquiétudes et que vous commenciez à
regarder les stocks de masques
pendant ce temps-là président de la
république nous expliquer que le virus
n'avait ni passeport ni frontières et
qu'il fallait sortir au théâtre et au
cinéma
donc j'aimerais comprendre pourquoi est
ce que nos dates on n'arrive pas à voir
pour comprendre et réels liés et réagir
face à une crise et en tirer une leçon
il faut bien partir d'un calendrier de
ce qui se passe l'un déroulé je
m'arrêterai là mais vraiment j'aimerais
comprendre pourquoi on n'arrive pas à
avoir un déroulé précis à telle date
voilà ce qui s'est passé et voilà la
réaction merci et merci muriel jourda
merci monsieur le président mes
questions sont en réalité celle de
madame annie d'helmand qui a dû
s'absenter et elles sont relatives il y
en a 3 rapide à un éventuel vaccin
les deux premières sont relatifs à la
recherche d'un vaccin c'est donc à
monsieur fontanet que que je m'adresse
il y a semble-t-il de nombreuses
recherches menées par des organismes
publics comme privés à travers le monde
sur un vaccin
la première question est de savoir si
regarde l'ensemble de ces projets vous
pouvez nous préciser à quelle étape de
recherches on en est d'un point de vue
global et la deuxième question de savoir
quel gage de sécurité pour nous disposés
dans la mesure où le délai de
développement semble extrêmement courts
par rapport à un délai de développement
classique qui serait de l'ordre de 10
ans la troisième question est relative
au cas du vaccin qui est actuellement
développé par l'institut pasteur
ce vaccin développé par l'institut
pasteur a vu sa licence rachetée par le
groupe merck msd ray faute de
financement faute de soutien financier
suffisant
vous avez annoncé avoir signé un
protocole qui permettra d'assurer un
accès équitable à travers le monde à ce
vaccin étant donné la demande
extrêmement forte qui découlera de
l'éventuelle réussite de ces essais
quelles garanties
l'institut pasteur a concrètement obtenu
pour que ce vaccin soit rapidement mis à
disposition des patients français
merci victoire jasmin
merci monsieur le président oui j'ai
plusieurs questions qui sont plutôt pour
le monsieur le préfet mais madame la
présidente mans alors les premières
questions
avez-vous des contrats locaux de santé
là c'est pour l'ensemble des contrats
locaux de santé des 6 pts
au niveau organisationnel pour les
communautés alors là c'est plus pour
l'arrivée ne dit pas la région et aussi
les soignants et payet toit de la grèce
voilà je voulais également savoir s'il
serait opportun de mettre en place un
plan de continuité des activités
partagées et complémentaires pour
l'ensemble des acteurs sur votre
territoire être les premiers c'est pas
toujours évident c'est vrai vous avez eu
beaucoup de difficultés mais j'ai vu au
niveau du commandement opérationnel vip
est ce que vous avez pu monsieur le
préfet avec toutes les difficultés que
vous avez rencontrées qui ont été
évoqués par monsieur vosges et sommiers
un des rapporteurs
concernant les équipements et là je suis
assez d'accord avec ce que vous avez dit
monsieur le professeur totani parce
qu'il y avait eu il ya quelques mois au
sénat où seule la commission des
affaires sociales un débat concernant
les dispositifs médicaux et j'avais
évoqué la situation du laboratoire
j'avais parlé des problèmes qu'il y
avait justement concernant les contrats
d'exclusivité pour cet équipement des
marchés négociés qu'il y avait et des
fermetures évidemment parce que tous les
consommables
parce que vous avez parlé des réactifs
mêlée ce sont aussi les consommables
parce que quand on a un et certains
équipements notamment pour la pcr et
bien on ne peut pas utiliser tous les
consommables et les réactifs pour cet
équipement et ça a bloqué aussi parce
que la même si vous aviez des réactifs
de disponible tous les laboratoires que
pas forcément équipés pour pouvoir
utiliser sur terre et actif qui étaient
déjà commercialisés
mais il ya également les problématiques
qui sont liées à la fiabilité la
fiabilité des premiers tests qui ont été
je ne sais pas à distribuer aux miss le
marché j'en sais rien
mais il y avait des problèmes de
fiabilité et il ya eu probablement aussi
des faux négatifs des réactions croisées
dans la mesure où au début de cette
pandémie
il ya une jeune adolescente qui a été
hospitalisé qui a eu un test négatif
puis ensuite positif et qui est
malheureusement décédé donc on voit bien
qu'il y avait quand même des limites
dans ce qui était sur le marché en tout
cas utilisé à l'époque et ma dernier en
question c'était c'est surtout pour le
ch par contre le centre hospitalier
alors au niveau de l'organisation de la
sortie des patients parce que les
premiers patients qui sont sortis de
réanimation n'ont pas été à mon avis
suffisamment accompagner dans la mesure
où un jeune qui est resté trois semaines
jeune homme père de famille qui est
resté trois semaines en réanimation
alors je ne je ne sais pas si à
plusieurs sens que je ne vais pas cibler
les autres mais comme en tant que
directrice de le centre hospitalier est
ce jeune a été renvoyée par une
ambulance à son domicile à l'anc sens
avec un masque sans une ordonnance pour
une éventuelle prise en charge de soins
psychologiques que se soit inclinée
qu'en fait bon y a eu aucun
accompagnement et c'est son épouse
enceinte qui a dû faire toutes les
démarches pour trouver dans une ville
voisine parce qu'on était encore en
confinement
alors c'était difficile de trouver un
kiné c'est difficile de trouver des
masques à la pharmacie alors que cette
dans cette famille ce père de famille
qu'est un jeune homme
son épouse est enceinte et il avait déjà
deux enfants donc aucune mesure
particulière pour un accompagnement à la
sortie mais pour éviter éventuellement
quand il sonne encore terminée parce
qu'on avait peu d'informations
concernant ce virus et jusqu'à
maintenant d'ailleurs
donc concernant une éventuelle l'huile
est resté trois semaines arias et son et
santi et il a su à sa sortie que toutes
les personnes qui étaient avec lui et en
même temps que lui malheureusement était
décédé donc là je crois qu'il y a eu
aussi à ce niveau là c'est vrai que
c'est difficile d'être les premiers dont
on n'a pas de modèle on n'a pas pour
ceux qui sont arrivés après ayons eu à
avoir les mêmes difficultés sur
territoire on peut être bénéficier des
expériences préalable les vôtres mais
c'était compliqué donc la dernière chose
monsieur le président je vais dire que
le sénat a fait un rapport récent
en 2018 et en 2019 concernant les
risques naturels majeurs parmi les
différentes recommandations sur que ce
soit sur la partie prévention monsieur
la particule concerne la résilience est
bien dans ses rapports et un certain
nombre de recommandations qu'on pourrait
utiliser pour les pandémies
malheureusement ce n'est pas mentionnée
dedans mais je crois que ce serait une
éventuelle piste de travail et culture
merci beaucoup merci victoire marie
pierre de la gontrie
merci président très rapidement
premièrement concernant la base
militaire de creil mais je vais vraiment
à l'appui des propos de notre collègue
paco et il serait sans doute très
intéressant que nous convoquerons devant
cette commission denquête les
responsables de la base militaire pour
pouvoir aller au fond du sujet le
deuxième point c'est février au fil des
auditions on voit que c'est la période
au cours de laquelle on ne comprend pas
très bien ce qui s'est passé
concrètement le directeur de la rs a
indiqué que les premières instructions
ou alerte je ne sais pas comment on doit
le dire était du 23 janvier aurélien
rousseau dg de la rs avait donné des
dates analogues mais on n'arrive pas à
identifier ce qui s'est passé dans cette
période là donc on demande des
précisions de deux dates
je pense que ça s'adresse sans doute
plus aux préfets et aux directeurs d'une
adresse d'ailleurs
troisième chose on n'a pas du tout parlé
du transfert des patients
et pourtant je crois qu'il ya eu un
sujet lorsque certains ont dû être
transférés dans d'autres hôpitaux dans
une période où je crois savoir
on n'était pas totalement ne contrôlait
pas totalement tout le tout le sujet et
ont fait une dernière question aux
professeurs fontanet vous avez au détour
de la phrase tout à l'heure évoqué
l'existence de l'eau contaminée de test
et comme je n'en avais pas entendu
parler ce qui n'est pas un critère mais
est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus merci il a écouté je
vais passer la parole on va commencer
par madame la directrice puisque elle
avait un répondre aussi sujet précédent
a fait donc pour répondre à votre
question sur les actions mises en place
à l'hôpital de crépy en valois je pense
qu'il sert de refaire une chronologie
des premiers jours en fait deux
de la crise au sein d'établissements
pour comprendre pourquoi on a pris ces
mesures
donc le mercredi 26 février en début
d'après midi
on me signale qu'il ya un début
d'épidémie d'infections respiratoires
aiguës sur le site 7e mari de la hante
et sur le service du sld
on est à une petite dizaine de cas qu'on
décide alors de faire ce qu'on fait
habituellement dans le cas d'une
épidémie c'est à dire de prendre des
mesures sanitaires à savoir renforcer le
bio nettoyage servir les repas en
chambre pour les personnes symptomatique
mettre à disposition du matériel de
protection pour le personnel suspendre
les animations suspendre les visites des
deux sites concernés par l'épidémie
l'après midi enfin en fin d'après midi
j'apprends que le médecin traitant de la
première victime
donc du coup vide est un médecin
traitant qui intervient au sein de nos
ehpad
j'alerte donc sur cette situation et je
décide de faire une réunion de crise
le jeudi matin donc le jeudi matin on se
retrouve et on décide au vu du contexte
de ce décès de cette première victime du
coup vide on décide de fermer également
le troisième site par mesure de
prévention et on décide de distribuer
des masques ffp2 au personnel on en
profite avec la venue donc du directeur
général de la rs sur la commune devant
moi et à crépy en valois pour informer
de la situation
et on apprend donc que le médecin en
question a été mis donc en 14 n par
mesure de prévention jusqu'au 4 mars
le vendredi 28 février
on décide toujours dans le cadre de ce
contexte de cette victime du conte à
virus on décide de confinée en chambre
l'ensemble des résidents et des patients
à l'exception de l'unité alzheimer qui
accueille des personnes déambulant en
temps et pour lesquels la mesure
s'applique dans la limite de sa
faisabilité
on décide donc de servir tous les repas
en chambre pour l'ensemble des résidents
et on décide de renforcer le personnel
pour le week end le samedi 29
on apprend que deux de nos résidents
hospitalisés dans d'autres
établissements du territoire sont
positifs au courant d'un virus on fait
donc une réunion de crise on prévient la
rs on a à ce moment là 34 cas
d'infections respiratoires aiguës sur
nos trois sites et on commence à avoir
des arrêts maladie de notre personnel
qui a été en contact notamment en usld
et on décide donc de commander des deux
pays fin des équipements de protection
individuelle supplémentaires on décide
de commandes et de l'oxygène
supplémentaires on décide de suspendre
toutes les entrées et les admissions
dans l'ensemble des services et on
demande à la rs ce dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure d'avoir donc des masques ffp2
supplémentaires ce qu'on obtient non dès
lundi nous deux mille masques et on leur
demande de nous appuyer sur notre
demande de prélèvement des cas
symptomatiques la semaine suivante
barles chu d'amiens pour tester donc
l'ensemble de ces personnes
symptomatique et le personnel qui serait
également symptomatique
le dimanche 1er mars on informe le
conseil départemental de la situation on
se réunit à nouveau et on constate que
certains médecins traitants sont arrêtés
et qu'on fini car il avait été en
contact avec des personnes
donc contrairement à ce que vous avez pu
dire tout à l'heure c'est vrai que enfin
tous les ehpad rattachés à des hôpitaux
n'ont pas forcément de médecin permanent
et c'était notre cas nous avions la
chance d'avoir un médecin on a toujours
la chance d'avoir un médecin
coordonnateur
qui a pris le relais de tous les
médecins traitants et elle a dû
s'occuper pendant une assez longue
période
donc de suivre 179 personnes parce
qu'aucun médecin traitant ne pouvait
venir sur l'établissement
ensuite le lundi 2 mars
on organise la journée de prélèvement
qui doit se dérouler le mardi 3 et 4
mars et on vit ce que monsieur le maire
évoquait tout à l'heure il monsieur
préfère un petit peu tout le monde à la
pression de la presse qui commencent à
arriver donc en bas d'établissement pour
avoir des informations
au final on aura pu tester le mercredi 4
mars 1 50 résidents symptomatique sur
les sur le manque sur l'ensemble de
l'établissement et le professeur schmidt
qui était venu donc effectuer ces
prélèvements nous avait dit à l'époque
on était encore sur des suspicions enfin
on pensait encore que c'était des
infections respiratoires aiguës et le
professeur schmidt me dis qu'il faut si
dizaine de prélèvements sont positifs
sur les 50 parce qu'il pourra pas par
son analyse et les 50 cas il faut
considérer l'ensemble en fait de nos
résidents symptomatique comme positif au
courant d'un virus le mercredi 4 mars
donc on a 50 cas donc sur
l'établissement on a alors
déjà quelques hospitalisation on a à peu
près dix personnes qui sont
hospitalisées sur le territoire le jeudi
5 mars
on teste 42 agents on se rend compte au
fur et à mesure que le personnel va être
une vraie problématique puisque beaucoup
de personnel sont touchées et en demande
et on l'avait demandé
des
dès le lundi à la rs on demande le
renfort de la réserve sanitaire qu'on a
pu obtenir dès la semaine suivante
alors non le 4 mars on se rend compte de
l'ampleur de la situation en avait déjà
alerté dès le 2 mars de ses possibles
arrêts du personnel et on peut on a pu
bénéficier du coup de la réserve
sanitaire dès la semaine suivante
oui bien sûr donc pour répondre à votre
question sur les mesures prises voici
l'ensemble des mesures qu'on a prises
dans les premiers jours de l'épidémie
je passe la parole maintenant dans par
rapport aux questions qui ont été posées
on va reprendre ce le préfet vous voyez
monsieur le président bon tout d'abord
je crois pour monsieur sénateurs qui est
intervenait sur la problématique de
trouver le bon interlocuteur est d'avoir
une bonne compréhension du calendrier
j'ai à votre disposition sur pour lier
l'avoir transmis hier le déroulement
chronologique de la pandémie dans le
département de l'oise voilà date par
date jour par jour
il ya tous les éléments qui ont été
collationner sur l'activation de telle
ou telle structure les numéros me et mis
en oeuvre
donc on pourra se présenter d'accord
vous le communiqué ensuite sur les
questions qui ont été posées concernant
une part la base de creil
mais aussi sur les forces de l'ordre et
les enseignants pour la base de creil je
voudrais quand même précisé que le
colonel cunac la base aérienne de creil
a été convié par mes soins a participé à
la deuxième conférence de presse avec
les organes de presse nationaux et
locaux qui avait lieu le 29 février
cette occasion les journalistes présents
ont pu poser toute une série de
questions qui sont d'ailleurs sensible
aux vôtres qui sont à peu près les mêmes
et il y a répondu donc ça aussi on peut
mais ce président nous aurons l'occasion
de l'auditionner nous était demandé nous
le ferons un moment venu mais vous voyez
bien que compte tenu du nombre
d'intervenants on peut pas non plus les
multiplier donc on ne peut pas forcément
répondre à toutes ces questions précises
mais on refera une audition bien
spécifique en ce qui concerne la base
militaire alors ensuite concernant les
enseignants dans l'oise ce qui était mis
sur pied ses 150 pôle d'accueil au
profit notamment des enfants des
personnels soignants pour permettre au
personnel soignant de se rendre dans
l'établissement hospitalier et de venir
en renfort des équipes déjà en place
donc pour ces enfants effectivement ses
épaules d'accueil ont été déployés sur
l'ensemble du département avec un
maillage disons très équilibré et il a
fallu bien évidemment fournir à ces
enseignants volontaires qui aussi au
personnel que je n'oublie pas communaux
et du conseil départemental qui ont été
dépêchés sur ses 150 pôle d'accueil
faire en sorte qu'ils aient les
équipements nécessaires pour se protéger
eux mêmes ce qui a été fait pour les
enseignants ils ont eu quatorze mille
masques qui ont des étaient distribués
par la directrice académique des
services de l'éducation nationale pro
profite donc de ses enseignants et cela
a été fait début avril
ensuite la préfecture qui a disposé d'un
stock de masques très important est venu
en appui pour compléter si nécessaire
lorsque les enseignants déployés sur ses
pôles d'accueil s'avérait pour certains
en situation de rupture pour ce qui
concerne la gendarmerie on va parler de
la brigade de mouiller voyez plus que si
bjarne sociaux nature parler de l'unité
de sûreté urbaine circonscription de
sécurité publique de creil où le nombre
de policiers touchés par la pandémie
était bien plus important bon tout
d'abord je suis allé les voir je vais
les voir savoir exactement sur les seize
gendarmes qui avaient été touchés et
quelles étaient les difficultés vous
pouvez rencontrer les gendarmes de façon
générale ont reçu des masques comme la
police nationale mais des masques ffp2
ils ont reçu d'ailleurs très tôt
courant mars comme les masques ffp2
était quand même une denrée
les relativement rares et surtout utile
aux personnels soignants
donc on les a demandé de nous les rendre
et on les a orientés vers la rs qui les
a orientés à son tour vers les
personnels soignants
voilà ce qui s'est passé pour pour les
masses donc pas d'autres consignes que
celle-là ensuite évidemment des jours
qui ont suivi de carence de masques pour
les forces de l'ordre policiers
gendarmes se sont fait connaître et donc
tu es que le stock nous a été
communiquée nous a été transmis à la
préfecture
moi j'ai procédé service par service
forces de l'ordre inclura tous les
services déconcentrés de l'état à une
distribution de masques chirurgicaux
pour de quoi tenir environ deux mois par
structure il ya également les sapeurs
pompiers vous auriez également pu en
parler qui ont lanka de leurs
interventions des masques ffp2 et pour
les personnes qui est qu'ils sont
secourus et masques chirurgicaux ils ont
été un moment en situation de rupture de
masques chirurgicaux malgré les
commandes passées auprès d'une société
c'est ça très loin de versailles des
sociétés medellin et là il a fallu bien
évidemment pour reprendre l'expression
de monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
jeu nié que le jeune ayant en appui pour
permettre aux pompiers d'obtenir ces
masses donc tout ça on l'a fait en bonne
intelligence avec bon sens en jaugeant
comme je lé fais d'ailleurs des zones
étroites avec le directeur de la rs et
la présence du conseil départemental
pour les établissements plus que les
ehpad
on a vérifié l'autonomie dont
disposaient chacun de ces services pour
éviter les situations de rupture donc
ont localisé très précisément là
l'autonomie de chacun de ces services
et quand il a fallu les approvisionner
en masse pour éviter problématique de
rupture et bien on l'a fait vous avez
signalé deux parlementaires je souscris
complètement olivier dassault et un
bureau bonnart c'est vrai sont venus
en appui pour le premier auprès des
opérateurs funéraires puisqu'il y avait
un nombre d'équipements que j'avais
listé de façon très précise pour
permettre à ces opérateurs funéraires
d'intervenir en heure étant dans les
hôpitaux puisque les morgues l'hôpital
hier était complètement engorgé il a
fallu le président intervenir auprès de
l'opérateur national au gf pour mettre
en place un dépôt des corps des
personnes décédées donc des pour
réfrigérer de circonstance un petit peu
autonomes à proximité des deux hôpitaux
de compiègne et beauvais
donc tout ça on l'a fait c'était une
espèce de forme de conduite
opérationnelle vous disais tout à
l'heure sur un ancien militaire pour
écouter je perds pas mais réflexe donc
la conduite opérationnelle ça veut dire
suivre au jour le jour la situation
chacun ses établissements et puis voir
où sont les possibilités de renforcement
et des ressources dont ils ont besoin ce
qui sont intégrés dans la gestion de
crise voilà ce que je peux venir
merci actuellement tout le monde les
stocks nécessaires si jamais il y avait
une reprise tout le monde est équipée à
monsieur le directeur de l'ars rsa les i
alors je vous préciserai puisque l'heure
tourne
alors je rappelle une nouvelle fois et
est ce que c'est vraiment tout est là
nous sommes les premiers
nous sommes les premiers ça a beaucoup
de conséquences
par exemple quand d'autres régions ont
été dans l'épidémie les distribution de
masques nationale avait déjà commencé
déjà faut jamais oublier ça je suis pas
sûr que ce soit un dysfonctionnement
c'est comme ça enfin je veux dire à ce
moment là les distributions de masse
n'ont pas commencé
d'autres seront après et bénéficions
d'ailleurs de notre expérience
donc effectivement jusqu'au 18 20 et 23
mars quand la distribution de masques se
fait donc à partir notre pour l'épauler
pour les officines avant il y en a pas
donc on a effectivement les
collectivités locales l'ont bien
raconter ou fait feu de tout bois pour
essayer d'aider nous de même nous avons
fait pareil on a récupéré certains
stades des dons on a pu et on a fait
avec avec tous les moyens on a tous fait
juste donne quelques exemples j'ai donné
tout à l'heure l'exemple d'ailleurs man
la directrice a mentionné les apports
qui ont été faites au coeur du coeur du
cluster avec ses masques ont admis 32
mille masques sur les yeux sms joly dit
tout à l'heure nous avons par exemple
servi aussi les adh su à partir du 20
août le 29 février nous avons distribué
des masques dans les maisons médicales
de garde pour les débats né s'est pas
des grandes quantités nous n'en avions
pas des stocks mais nous avons nous
avons nous avons fait avec ce que nous
pouvions
à partir du 9 mars par exemple nous
donnons des masques à sos médecins
donc voilà on a comme tout le monde en
fait je dirais on a tous mobilisés nos
capacités pour pour avoir cette période
où il n'avait pas encore les dotations
nationales mais parce que nous étions et
nous avons fait je crois au mieux je
suis sur la question des est donc
ensuite pour dire sur les enquêtes pour
répondre à la question nous avons joué
dit tout à l'heure
ensuite mis en quête permanente qui nous
a permis justement de monitorer de
vérifier si jamais un établissement
avait moins de trois jours nous faisions
ou bien des dépannages interhospitalier
ou bien grâce aux stocks
avec le temps nous avons pu constituer
au niveau de l'agencé que nous avions
répartis sur l'ensemble des départements
comme je vais revenir en des plus de
manière plus détaillée sur évidemment la
question des professionnels de santé de
ville puisque monsieur le sénateur paco
vous m'avez notamment interrogé sur ce
sujet alors je nous avons immédiatement
ça a été vraiment une préoccupation
fondamentale d'associer profondément la
médecine de ville à à la question je
redis c'est pas ce que dit monsieur pas
comme j'ai bien entendu mais il ya deux
ans donc je vois donc d'élever à ce que
disent les toubibs surtout pardon c'est
ce n'est pas ce que m'ont dit de non
moins ils sont professionnels et
châteaux si vous me permettez je vais
répondre le 28 février première
conférence
avec donc immédiatement conférence avec
lui rps des médecins libéraux à partir
du 3 mars conférence avec l'ensemble des
ups tout ça va se faire ensuite de
manière permanente nous ferons ensuite
plusieurs fois par semaine des
conférences téléphoniques
nous avons aussi des conférences commune
avec l'ordre y compris avec l'assurance
maladie
nous avons aussi à plusieurs reprises et
ça c'était une initiative des deux lui
rps des webinaires qui ont permis de
toucher énormément de praticiens j'ai
même participé un d'entre eux plus de
400 médecins nous ont permis d'en donc
ce que je veux dire par là sur la région
sur la région rue les champs
départementale le travail se fait
évidemment les lords régler au niveau
départemental 1 ces réunions elles se
font niveau départemental je rappelle
juste une chose c'est que et c'est
toujours un sujet honnêtement important
et il ya une part de malentendu sur les
ars les ars
même si certains médias disent le
contraire ce sont des structures dont la
taille ne leur permet pas d'être au
contact direct avec il ya cent mille
hospitalier dans la région il ya six ans
médecin généraliste rien que dans l'oise
les personnes qui s'occupent de
l'ambulatoire à la rs auto de france
pour toute la région c'est une
quarantaine de personnes les personnes
qui s'occupent de tout l'hôpital
un des cent mille hospitaliers de
l'hôpital
rien qu'au chu de lille il ya seize
mille personnes ils sont une centaine
donc nous notre travail s'est articulé
et c'est notamment d'articuler des
réseaux avec les hôpitaux y aller j'ai
acheté c'est une très bonne innovation
avec les professionnels nous passons
avant tout par les huées ps avec lequel
nous avons des relations
vraiment je dirais
vraiment de pop de coordination et c'est
eux leurs relais de la même manière des
ces femmes ont des troupes beaucoup plus
importante
un des délégués de l'assurance maladie
et d'état alors ce qui est vrai c'est
que tout ça nous le faisons ensemble
mais que le professionnel de terrain lui
c'est pas la rs qui ne voit évidemment
puisque nous sommes nous travaillons en
relais et ça ça se fait au niveau
régional mais surtout au niveau
départemental donc moi je dis juste on
vend on en voit souvent notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux des professeurs qui
dit moi je ne vois jamais la rs mais la
rs elle travaille justement de manière
indirecte
cela dit j'en profite quand même bien
ensuite je vais venir vraiment sûr sur
le lac estion la mise en oeuvre sur la
question toute la quête est posée tout à
l'heure par monsieur le sénateur ronia
numéro de téléphone
moi je peux vous le dire 1 la rs et son
numéro et sur son site internet
elle a un numéro d' alerte elle a un
mail d'alert ce numéro il est actif 24
heures sur 24 24 heures sur 24
je l'avais même rediffusé via le
bulletin à tous les élus parce que en
fait il se passe parfois que les gens
appellent les gens qui connaissent la
nuit éventuellement cette personne dort
cette seule c'est normal mais on a une
astreinte 24 heures sur 24 vous allez
sur le site de la rs 24 heures sur 24
vous pouvez joindre la rs sur ce numéro
unique
je viens maintenant vraiment sur les
questions de prise en charge alors je
rappelle une fois de plus nous sommes
les premiers
or quand nous sommes au tout début de
l'épidémie
nous sommes sur une doctrine nationale
de prise en charge exclusivement
hospitalière et ça c'est une doctrine
classique en cas de virus émergents les
patients doivent être pris et doivent
être mis en chambre par clairement
protéger impression positive et c'est au
départ on a même un au tout début
les patients sont même envoyés au chu de
lille qui est le seul sûr sûr sûr sûr la
région donc là nous avons déjà et
heureusement d'ailleurs parce qu'on n'a
pas forcément non plus les moyens de le
faire ensuite nous avons travaillé avec
les médecins de ville et dans le cadre
des réunions dont j'ai parlé pour
vraiment l'ordre le travailler avec eux
en construction
pour sur la base des éléments connus un
certain nombre de conduites à tenir le
15 mars
nous avons élaboré avec eux un arbre
décisionnel de prise en charge qui
ensuite a été révisé dès le 5 mars en
travaillant avec les médecins au
déploiement des centres qu'ovide et aux
flux dédié dans les msp
nous avons eu à la fois et ça a été
différent suivant les départements de la
région différenciation
car nous avons toujours souhaité que ce
soit les professionnels qui détermine
les modalités qu'il souhaitait dans
certains départements ils ont préféré
des centres qu'ovide dans d'autres c'est
le cas dans l'oise ils ont plutôt
privilégié même s'il y avait des centres
qu'ovide les maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelle parce que c'était
plutôt eu leur structure et donc nous
avons en permanence avec un financement
à rs mis en place à semble de structures
qui leur permettait de de réagir en
fonction de ce qu'il préférait et la
grosse différenciation je le dis très
clairement
entre autres départements nous avons
aussi déployé dès le début mars une
solution de télémédecine ouvert d'abord
à tous les médecins généralistes puis à
tous les professionnels de santé
nous avions le 4 mars pour les médecins
généralistes le 5 alors que le 4 mars
dans l'oise le 5 dans toute la région
au total ces sept mille professionnels
de santé sur la région qui ont rejoint
notre programme régional que nous avons
prédit ce qui est soutenu par le conseil
régional
je voulais dire aussi que et 7 points il
a été souligné à plusieurs reprises très
important la question de la présence
médicale dans les ehpad la décision que
j'ai prise au mois de mars
c'est de financer sur les crédits à rs
le passage au temps plein des médecins
coordonnateurs c'est à dire que tout
médecin coordonnateur qui souhaitait
qu'ils pouvaient passer d'un temps
partiel 20% 50% à 100%
j'avais annoncé que la totalité de sa
rémunération serait prise en charge
directement par les rays cette
initiative que j'ai prise et qui était
financé directement par l' agence voilà
sur ces différents points pour le jeu
revient ensuite sur la question 2
madame chasma sur l'essai pts
alors nous avons six et pts dans l'oise
en cours de développement
c'est encore une structure en devenir un
en tout cas je crois que l'unanimité se
fait sur ceux de cette organisation
là encore et je vous dis moi je crois
profondément à ça la logique qui part du
terrain qui part de l'organisation de la
philosophie de la cpsc que nous venons
en appui
nous payons l'agencé régionale de santé
paye l'ingénierie parce que souvent les
professeurs de santé ont des idées mais
au niveau de la formalisation ça peut
être trop administrative dont nous
payons une aide à formaliser ce qu'on
appelle le projet et ensuite nous
développons mais l'essai pts pour moi
c'est l'avenir c'est l'avenir parce que
c'est vraiment une approche territoriale
qui permet effectivement et je crois que
là où l'essai pts et est développé
on a vu que c'était vraiment un plus
madame de la gontrie sur le mois de
février je pense que donc on veut
monsieur le préfet a répondu on donnera
de toute façon toutes les chronologies à
l'écrit c'est forcément plus plus simple
qu'à l'oral sur les transferts de
patients il ya eu évidemment un des
transferts de patients tout au long de
la période
je dire c'est aussi pour ça que la
dimension régionale est importante
ça a été évoqué par plusieurs à
plusieurs reprises le chu d'amiens
c'est évidemment à la fois une expertise
et une capacité de transfert qui est
évidemment extrêmement importante et il
y a eu bien sûr c'est vrai qu'ils
effectueraient top-team des transferts
alors en fait les transferts c'est
vraiment ça peut être ponctuel
individuelles y en a toute l'année des
transferts ça c'est avant tout le métier
de la régulation médicale des seins nus
samu départementale s'amuse zone y
compris entre samu et là moi ce sont des
décisions médicales je n'ai pas à
intervenir là dessus et mon principe
c'est toujours c'est les médecins qui
décident ensuite dans le cadre la crise
telle qu'elle a été comme je vous disais
nous avions tous les jours à 16 heures
30 la conférence audio avec les cinq
samu dont les vides à molsheim une zone
est donc assez
un moment notamment justement quand la
pression mais là je parle d'une date
postérieure à celle que nous avons
évoqués quand il ya eu le problème de la
tension sur la réanimation
là il ya eu des décisions collectives et
une fois de plus je le dis tout ça se
nous avons pris tous des décisions qui
étaient collectives il s'avère que
j'avais la chance à la rs d'avoir un
médecin réanimateur au sein de la rs et
donc il parlait aussi à l'ensemble de
ses collègues tous les jours nous avions
une enquête quotidienne sur l'état et
ses transferts il se faisait toujours en
collégialité en et lance alors
essentiellement en ambulance il ya eu un
transfert héliporté de 10 patients au
mois d'avril
ok merci chez le préfet rapidement est
prêt il ya dans le domaine de la prise
en charge pour compléter ce qui était
dit par directeur général de la rs
conseiller utile que vous sachiez
on a déployé une unité particulière pour
les sans domicile fixe 110 sans domicile
fixe ont été pris en charge localement
avec le soutien de la rs et les services
de l'état locaux dans l'établissement
qui était vide à cette occasion de
l'établissement public de l'insertion
pour la défense l'epide parce que les
sans domicile fixe pouvait être eux
mêmes des vecteurs de propagation donc
ces initiatives que nous avons prises
c'est sûr dans les choses bien je pense
que c'en est une et si nous avions à
affronter une nouvelle vague épidémique
eh bien je pense que c'est une
expérience qui mérite d'être étudiée à
une échelle bien supérieur c'est la
département
deuxième point ça n'a pas été dit mais
c'est un peu un élément important dans
le département de l'oise et un aéroport
et que des des compagnies qui assurent
des vols low cost et donc ces vols ont
été assurés pendant le mois de février
pendant le mois de mars est d'ailleurs
ces vols nous poser des soucis notamment
les vols en provenance de l'italie l'un
d'entre vous intervenez tout à l'heure
pour se dire quelle était la situation
en italie et donc son impact sur
territoire national nous avions mis en
place un dispositif qui était
relativement simple mais qui s'avère
efficace à dire dès lors qu'ils avaient
des passagers qui dans certains vols ont
manifesté des symptômes on les prenait
en charge immédiatement dès lors
à l'aéroport en isolant un terminal sur
sur deux ans les prenaient en charge
directement par le samu hospitalisation
de ces personnes contaminées et toutes
celles et ceux qui étaient en contact
avec celle-ci obligation de confinement
pendant les quatorze jours j'allais dire
réglementaire voilà ce qui a été mis en
place qui pourrait l'être d'ailleurs
dans d'autres départements
si ils étaient confrontés à ce genre de
situation très bien merci
vous enchaînez madame la présidente je
vous le dis on met un point après ça ils
se leurrent oui alors cinq minutes
encore 5 minutes encore pour finir les
questions ville est question pour
monsieur fontanes et donc très
rapidement sa vallée mais puisque j'ai
qu'une question simplement une précision
avant d'aborder les aînés isolés
concernant les ctps est important
effectivement de développer au sein du
département pour l'oise donc le
département participe à l'achat du
matériel aussi en quête de
l'investissement voilà concernant les
aînés isolés
ça a été une de mes principales
préoccupations parce que on pouvait
travailler y assurer que les ehpad le
département gère plutôt des publics
fragiles les ehpad il ya une structure
on prend les établissements les foyers
pour de l'enfance ils ont des structures
on va tout est structuré en ce qui
concerne les personnes isolées souvent
elles ont affaire à un stade et en ce
qui concerne les stades on ne sont pas
des professionnels de santé personnes de
plein de bonne volonté mais pas
spécialement des personnels de santé
donc il ya eu vraiment cette peur au
démarrage ce qui fait que tous les jours
nous avions également l'esad au
téléphone pour savoir si des pins des
agents qui travaillent dans les salles
passait bien voir les personnes âgées
on s'est vite rendu compte qu'il y avait
environ 1000 personnes qui n'étaient
plus suivis c'est à dire que souvent les
personnes âgées disent ah non moi je
veux pas du passage du sad
moi je suis seul je suis chez moi
je suis moins confrontés aux virus et
par conséquent si ça vient de
l'extérieur je risque de l'attraper mais
là ça commençait à poser un véritable
problème et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a créé d'abord un numéro
pouvoir répondre aux familles qui
s'appelait urgence seniors et donc ce
téléphone ce numéro a très bien marché
on a pu renseigner les personnes âgées
mais aussi les les familles et j'ai
demandé à mes services d'appeler les
mille personnes en question puisque les
salles avait fait remonter les personnes
qui ne souhaitent plus du pain le
passage et donc on a appelé ses mille
personnes donc certaines personnes nous
disent est effectivement la famille
prend le relais donc là c'était plutôt
bien
certaines nous le disait qu'on ne le
croyait pas vraiment et donc il a fallu
faire un vrai travail de fourmi auprès
de ses mille personnes et nous avons mis
en place un système avec les maires
c'est à dire que si c'était une ville
importante ont travaillé avec les ccas
si c'était une commune beaucoup moins
importantes ont travaillé que les mères
c'est à dire qu'une fois qu'on avait
l'information
eh bien on a pu appeler chaque personne
et se rendre compte si la personne était
isolé ou pas dans certains cas
effectivement les familles avaient pris
le relais le relais donc dans ce cas là
ça se passait bien mais il y avait des
personnes qui avaient bleus voilà pour
cette audition de différents
responsables du département de l'oise
département on s'en rappelle avait été
identifié l'un des tout premiers cluster
de coronavirus la commission denquête va
désormais poursuivre ses travaux on sera
bien évidemment amené à en reparler sur
notre antenne d'ici là excellente
journée sur public sénat la formation
politique et parlementaire continue